the moment you think differently you're
mapping new Connections in your brain if
you keep thinking differently it's going
to feel uncomfortable in the beginning
but nerve cells that fire together wire
together now you're beginning to create
networks of neurons to reflect a new
idea if you're able to then let the
thought in your mind become the
experience the end product of the
experience is an elevated emotion now
you turn off these survival centers that
have to do with your identity and all of
a sudden that energy starts moving into
your heart they're like Christmas tree
lights jees are like Christmas tree
lights they're turning on and off all
the time unless you're thinking the same
thoughts performing the same behaviors
and living by the same emotions now you
have the same lights on and the other
lights off now all genes make proteins
that's what they do your body's a
protein producing machine so if you keep
the same genes turned on you keep making
the same proteins nothing's going to
change in your life hey it's S car
Michael and I make these videos because
I need them because being around
successful entrepreneurs who are pushing
who are driving who are doing amazing
things gives me that extra little
motivational inspirational boost in the
morning morning every day to help me go
off and accomplish great things too and
I hope that this video gives you that
inspiration as well so today let's get
some incredible motivation from the one
and only Joe despenza
enjoy we have to um understand to a
greater degree that we are more
unlimited uh than what we're told uh
that we have to change our beliefs
that we if we live in fear of something
getting us uh what we fear has power
over us and and when we're in that
emotional state we we give it a lot of
our attention and where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so we have to be greater than our
environment we have to be greater than
the normal unconscious programs that we
don't have the power to heal in our body
and we have the time now the luxury of
time to be more in the present moment to
get get better at it when people have
this fear of death um they just don't
know what it looks like and and you know
every religion that I've studied and and
I don't spend a lot of time studying
religion but I have through my own
curious nature looked at several
religions uh throughout my life and
every religion talks about uh uh be this
concept of being Eternal whether you're
what religion it is either you go to
heaven you go to hell you go there for
eternity you're on the wheel of karma
you're on that wheel for eternity you're
in Nirvana it's eternity so this concept
that we are Consciousness that we're an
awareness uh and energy never is uh lost
in the universe I I think that um if we
embrace the idea that we are
Eternal and this is just a wink in in in
eternity uh then the question is am I
all in am I going to am I going to go
all in at this time in history and and
this is a time in history by the way
where we have all the practice that we
have done in our own work in our work
all of the knowledge we've learned all
the meditations all the Transformations
all the inquiries all the pushing
ourselves past our limits uh all the
training and practice of heart coherence
brain
coherence is for times like these these
are the times where it matters the most
this is now you have tools uh to
self-regulate you have tools so so
changing your relation reltionship with
the understanding of death death is not
uh a failure or the end it's just a
transition so so I just feel like um
when we confront that and we have a good
conversation about it uh and we really
we really find the answers about it I I
I think um we're we're more prone to be
less fearful uh uh uh in our lives and I
think that's important when the unknown
becomes an adventure you know you're
over the hormones of stress or at least
changing the hormones of stress because
the unknown is a scary place in survival
and stress and but when becomes an
adventurer it means now we're craving
the unknown and that's I think that's
one of the things I love the most about
our community that people really crave
the unknown I mean they their mind is
not limited in in any way and and you
got to if you believe in yourself you
got to believe in possibilities right
you got to if you believe in
possibilities you got to believe in
yourself and you're not going to get
possibilities sitting on the recliner
you got to go out and get them 95% of
Who We Are by the age of 35 is
programmed is that true I think if we
Define a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition The Habit is when you've done
something so many times that your body
now knows how to do it better than your
conscious mind then it's programmed
subconsciously so then when the body
knows how to do it better than the
conscious mind then for the most most
part the greatest habit we have to break
is the habit of being ourselves right so
there's a principle Neuroscience that
says that nerve cells that fire together
wire together if you keep thinking the
same way uh if you keep making the same
choices if you keep doing the same
things if you keep reproducing the same
experiences and feeling the same
emotions your biology begins to become
hardwired in a sense it be uh it becomes
programmed so in order to change
uh something to arrive at a new vision
of your future if you were wanted to
arrive at a new goal or New Vision of
your future you'd have to change
something about yourself in order to get
there and you'd have to change the way
you think the way you act and the way
you feel when you begin to become
conscious of those unconscious thoughts
so conscious that you don't let them
slip by your awareness unnoticed or
unchecked by you if you catch yourself
speaking in a limited way
or um you you become conscious that
you're behaving in a certain way in a
habit and you can notice or pay
attention to how you're feeling then
you're no longer the program now your
Consciousness observing the program
you're only unconscious when you're in
the program and so to change then is to
become so conscious that you don't don't
go unconscious again and in a sense that
is consciousness that is really the
puppet master that really decides who we
want to be
I think the biggest problem uh is that
people lose their free will uh to a set
of programs and so their body is
basically um programmed into a
predictable future based on what they've
done in the past so to change then to
change that habituation takes an
enormous amount of energy an enormous
amount of awareness also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there the best thing we could ever do
for the world is to work on
ourselves I mean we have three brains in
one and those three brains allow us to
go from thinking to doing to being the
thinking brain is the neocortex that's
where we learn information you learn
knowledge you learn semantics you learn
philosophy you learn intellectual data
you store that in your thinking
brain now it's not enough to just learn
that information you have to actually
apply it you have to demonstrate it you
have to get your body
involved and when you go from thinking
to doing and you actually modify your
behavior now you're going to have a new
experience and that new experience is
going to make a new emotion and that new
emotion is going to instruct the body
it's going to teach the body what the
mind is intellectually understood you
see knowledge is for the mind and
experience is for the body getting
people to go from thinking to doing is
like hurting cats cuz everybody wants to
stay in the int ual realm no one wants
to get their body involved everybody
wants to be a philosopher
right and so if you're going to read the
book on
peace and you're going to read the book
on on uh on uh global warming if you're
going to read the book on uh on uh
economics or a new a new a new uh way to
govern you can't just read the book you
got to now get out there and demonstrate
it you got to demonstrate peace you have
to be peace and it's not enough to just
do the experience once you can't have a
experience where you read the book on
peace and then you go and you experience
peace one time and say okay I I get the
Nobel Peace Prize you got to be able to
repeat that experience over and over
again and you got to make it look
natural and easy and when you do you
activate that third brain that third
brain allows us to be in a state of
being see when we're in a state of being
that's when mind and body are working
together and leaders great
leaders knew how to do that they weren't
saying one thing and doing body was
doing something else their mind and body
their intention was aligned to their
behavior and their behavior was equal to
their intention their thoughts and
actions were working together and when
that happens we move into a state of
being now imagine a world of people
demonstrating peace
so you can you can you can meditate in a
city and there have been experiments
that show the crime rates drop when
there the meditation is in process but
when that experiment ends the meditation
Returns the the crime rate returns back
to the cealing value when the meditation
is over so it's not enough to just think
it but imagine now if people are
actually demonstrating peace and
actually demonstrating they were the
living example of it
you would be have thousands of people in
a state of being being it so when the
mystics talked about being it it wasn't
enough to just say you can think about
it you have to actually embrace it it's
got to be visceral and you have to
memorize that emotional state so great
with such intensity that nothing from
your external world will move you from
it that's when we've mastered that state
of Peace just the thought alone could
create an emotion that could to make us
sick is that what I'm hearing yeah
because that thought when you're seeing
that thought in your mind or remembering
that image it's the image and the
emotion it's the thought and the feeling
it's the stimulus and response that's
immediately conditioning the body into
that state of imbalance so it's a
scientific fact that the long-term
effects of the harmones of stress push
the genetic buttons and create disease
if you can turn on that stress response
just by thought alone your thoughts are
literally going to make sick okay so
that's the greatest example of the Mind
Body Connection so the next fundamental
question is okay if our thoughts could
make us sick is it possible that my
thoughts could make me well well if
that's the case then then I'm going to
have to manage my
attention and I'm going to have to
manage my energy because where I place
my attention is where I place my energy
and I'm going to have to inhibit that
thought that has conditioned the body to
subconsciously be the mind of that
emotion and the body's so objective that
it does not know the difference between
the real life experience that's creating
that emotion and the emotion that person
is fabricating by thought alone to the
body it's exactly the same so the body's
believing it's being chased by a
predator the body is believing it's in
an an offensive situation where it has
to attack the body's believing it's
constantly needing to be ready and it's
it's constantly out of homeostasis is
constantly out of balance it's in
emergency it's in fight or flight it's a
different system in the anomic nervous
system where you're stepping on the gas
where you're you're mobilizing enormous
amounts of energy for some threat some
Danger real or
imagined but that thought and that
feeling the image the emotion the
stimulus response is conditioning the
body to automatically be the mind of
that emotion so then now the body
becomes conditioned and addicted now
this gets to be a problem because people
get addicted to their own thoughts
becomes their personality right it is
their identity and they become addicted
to the life they don't even like because
they response to the coworker to the
boss to the ex is actually giving them a
rush of energy A Rush of agine and
they're they're associating that Rush of
energy with some problem or condition in
their life and now come time to change
and manage your attention and manage
your emotion it's no different than
Breaking addiction to anything there's
Cravings the body the body wants to
return back to how it's been conditioned
into the familiar past into the gnome I
believe that there are latent systems in
the brain and body that have to be
activated in order for us to have a
lucid or mystical moment yeah and um
I've been chasing the mystical now for
at least 20 years and I think people
start out uh in a in a spiritual quest
for a lot of reasons some people want to
be abundant some people want to be
healthy some people want better
relationships and that's kind of the
reason why people start but as they
start creating things they want in their
life and as they start connecting uh to
this inv visible field of information
called the quantum field you know that's
a fre that field is made up of energy
and energy is frequency and all
frequency carries information when you
can hook up to that field then your
brain processes a new stream of
Consciousness and that Consciousness uh
uh coexists with energy so all of a
sudden you have a very transcendental
moment and your inner world uh starts
becoming more real than your outer world
and those moments then leave Lasting
Impressions in our brain because you
feel the energy of that experience and
when you feel altered in some way
because you feel more electric or more
alive you pay more attention to the
images in your brain and you're starting
to create memories and now the brain
becomes wired differently and I think
that you perceive a broader spectrum of
reality practice the meditation that
goes along with it now why is that
meditation important because I still do
that meditation when I'm in the process
of change I want to become conscious of
my unconscious thoughts I want to be
aware of how I speak how I act I want to
look at how I feel every single day and
see if that feeling is connected to my
future or is connected to my past and I
want to write all those things down and
remind myself to stay so conscious that
I don't go unconscious and return back
to that old personality that's connected
to the same life and then thinking about
thoughts you do want to fire and wire in
your brain and have them through
repetition with intention and attention
install the Circ and repeat it enough
times so that the hardware becomes more
like a software program and you
naturally have a new voice in your head
that says anything's possible believe in
yourself you can do this instead of I
can it's too hard I don't feel like it
those are thoughts of the past to sit
down and decide how you're going to be
with your children how you're going to
be in traffic how you're going to be
with co-workers what would love do and
and begin to review and rehearse in your
mind how you're going to be and the act
of rehearsing in your mind truly begins
to install more neurological Hardware
you're you're reminding yourself and
reproducing the same level of Mind why
so you can step into that footprint in
your day and modify your behaviors to
produce a different experience that
experience produces a different emotion
and you're going to want to feel that
emotion instead of the emotions of your
past and then teach your body what your
future feels like start making those
chemicals if you keep thinking the same
thoughts if you keep making the same
choices you keep doing the same things
you keep creating the same experiences
you keep feeling the same emotions I
don't know let's be
conservative you do that for 10
years you would have to agree with me
then that it would become more
automatically be become more
unconscious so your personality creates
your personal reality that's it that is
it and your personality is made of how
you think how you act and how you feel
so keep thinking the same way keep
acting the same way keep feeling the
same way your personality is the same
and your personality personal reality
would be the same as well so if you
wanted to change your life if you wanted
to change your personal reality you
would have to change your
personality and then you'd have to start
thinking about what you've been thinking
about and decide if you really want to
believe that any
longer and when does the story
end
it's it's that moment that you become so
conscious of that thought you're so
tired of it you're so aware of it that
you would never let it slip by your
awareness ever
again you catch yourself complaining and
blaming and making excuses and feeling
sorry for yourself and that's been your
unconscious program then the moment you
become conscious of those unconscious
behaviors you're out of the program
you're only in the program when you're
unconscious and so it takes an enormous
amount of energy and awareness to
separate from those programs and then
there's those emotions that we feel
every single day that are so familiar to
us that we don't even know what they are
we just feel guilty we don't even know
what's guilt is just how we
feel and the stronger the emotions that
we have to experiences in our life the
more altered we are inside of us when
the chemistry changes inside of us the
brain Narrows the focus on the cause and
takes a snapshot or a series of
snapshots and that's called a long-term
memory and so then makes total sense
then that a person by every time they
relive that event in their life they're
making the same chemistry in their brain
and as in their body and their bodies
literally believing it's living that
experience over and over
again and now the bodies so in the past
that it's the mind of the
past so
then the ACT of becoming so conscious
that you don't go unconscious is a
changing of
Consciousness how many times do we have
to
forget until we stop forgetting and
start remembering that is the moment of
change if you're living in stress and
you're living in survival and that
system is switched on then everything
will be a threat everything will be a
danger everything will be a reason to
rush to be impatient to be frustrated to
be judgmental because that's that's the
Consciousness that's the emotion living
by so now you you have a a problem with
a coworker you have a problem with your
partner whatever it is that you use as
an example and you have to give a
presentation now now you really have one
of two choices either be
victimized by those conditions in your
life and you stay in that emotional
state and I'll say to you Jay why are
you that way well I'm this way because
of this person the circumstance the
person or circumstan is controlling the
way I feel and the way I think anything
that controls the way I feel and the way
I think I'm victim to right okay or I
actually can be a Creator now okay so
when it's the hardest it matters the
most okay so there's going to be a story
a valid story that's going to go along
with those emotions that you're going to
have to give up that you can address at
another time from a different state if
you're altered in that state and you say
something you do something you write the
email you send the text you'll always
regret it you'll always say I should
have never said that I should have never
done that we got to learn that we're in
an altered state at that time so it's
only one of two choices you either stay
there the whole day and tell everybody
that story or you say okay let me take a
moment remember that this is the
experiment called life okay let me
practice getting relaxed in my heart let
me slow the animal down let me practice
that take a few minutes now let me
breathe let me get my state back let me
change everything okay let me remember
who I am who I want to be when I open my
eyes and let me practice that again now
even if you had to do that 10 times in
one day I would say it was a day worth
living I would say it was a day worth
living and when we do walking
meditations uh in our our Retreats we're
doing walking meditation so you can
practice doing it with your eyes open
like if you're going to be relaxed in
your heart and awake in your brain and
you can do it with your eyes close okay
let's take it out for a test drive let
me open my eyes let me pay a little bit
more attention to my inner World let me
practice feeling this feeling let me
practice feeling this way and let my
brain do what it does let me get defined
let me change my physiology let me
change my state let me walk as the
healed person let me walk as the
Abundant person let me walk as if my
prayers are answered me walk in the
state if I keep practicing that over and
over it's going to become a habit right
yeah so so we hit it as many ways as we
can we have at least seven or eight
different breaths that we do because we
see how they all work in the
brain we have all kinds of meditations
we have Sitting meditations we have
standing and walking meditations we have
laying down meditations because we want
you to be able to do it with your eyes
open with your eyes closed standing
walking any way you can so that you
don't default and return back to that
person now if you do default you didn't
fail that's a program you just went
unconscious and how many times do we
have to forget until we stop forgetting
and start remembering that's the moment
of change no one no one cares how many
times you fell off the bicycle if you
ride the bicycle now you ride the bike
so it's it's the constant process uh
every single day and I think that
sometimes we look for evidence in our
life and it hasn't happened and I think
it's so important that we still show up
yeah yeah cuz that's the that's where
you're changing the most and when you
get to that point where you could care
less if it happens or not CU you feel so
happy so grateful for who you are get
ready because your life is going to
begin to change in magical ways and
wouldn't you agree then if you were
changing a habit whether you wanted to
lose weight or stop smoking or stop
eating choc whatever people do you're
going to have to look at the things that
cause you to return back to the same
choice and you're going to review in
your mind oh my gosh I know that little
Devil's going to come up and say go
ahead you know start tomorrow
chocolate's good for you it's all right
you know everybody else is eating it you
know and you have to become selective
about that thought's going to come up
and you have to overcome that thought
would you agree because that thought's
going to lead to the same choice right
so you have to review in your mind who
you no longer want to
be and then you're going to have to
observe your behaviors and as you begin
to observe your behaviors you're going
to have to make a decision with such
firm intention that the amplitude of
that decision carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardwired
programs in your brain and the emotional
addiction or memory in your body and
your body responds to a new mind it gets
a rush of energy and when it gets that
Rush of energy you're giving it a
sampling of the future you're grabbing
the reins of the stallion and you're
pulling those reins in and you're saying
I'm the boss and the body the animal
begins to respond to your
mind and then you have to look at the
emotions the feelings that you look
forward to whether it's guilt or shame
or unworthiness that's become so
familiar you don't even know that you're
feeling that way it just feels like you
and you have to decide then does this
emotion belong in my future future do I
want to bring this into my future
because as long as I'm living by this
emotion I'm living in my
past so then as you begin to observe
those states of Mind and Body you begin
to objectify your subjective self and
just like viewing a videotape of
yourself playing baseball playing tennis
dancing a dance speaking publicly
whatever it is if you can observe
yourself it means you can self-correct
better wouldn't you agree so then the
process of change then is becoming
conscious of your unconscious self and
when you begin to decide every day who
you no longer want to be you are you are
retiring the old self and the body will
crave the emotional payoff just like an
addiction and you have to understand
that that's the biological neurological
chemical hormonal physiological genetic
death of the old self and when you begin
to understand that you can work then in
creating a new self and you can begin to
emotionally give your body a taste of
the
future ahead of the actual event and as
we said last night the emotional
signature is exactly what signals the
gene because the body does not know the
difference between the actual experience
in your life that creates the emotion
and the the emotion that you're
fabricating by thought alone to the body
it's the same I started studying this
concept called neuroplasticity where it
says that we're not hardwired to be a
certain way for the rest of our lives
that the brain is adaptable and it's
changeable and we can rewire our brain I
started studying some of that research
and then I started studying epigenetics
that we're not doomed by our genes uh uh
that we are really marvels of
adaptability and change and and we could
literally uh signal new genes and change
our expression of of Gene potential and
I started thinking uh about how the mind
influenced the body and I had to study
uh psychon neuroimmunology
neurochemistry and and neuro hormones
and and then of course uh led me to
quantum physics and how subjective mind
has an effect on the objective world and
started this journey of uh understanding
my own personal
transformation and um I think after you
have an initiation like this and this
was my initiation it was my wakeup call
in fact I wouldn't be sitting here today
if it didn't happen to me U I think when
you have moments like this in your life
and you have uh some Transcendence of
your your conditions and you have a
breakthrough I don't think you can go
back to business as usual I don't think
you could go back to being the same
person again and I was in a lot of ways
that change a young man
and so I started my journey in in
looking to find answers and and did my
best to combine both the spiritual
understanding of what happened to me
with the
science and so after a period of time I
started studying spontaneous remissions
I I wanted to understand if if there
were other people um that had same or
similar conditions that were treating
conventionally or
unconventionally and they were staying
the same or getting worse and all of a
sudden they got better and I wanted to
know if there was a cause that somehow
produce the effect and so I interviewed
hundreds and hundreds of people uh that
had some type of spontaneous remission
and over time I began to realize that
those changes weren't so spontaneous
after all that there was some effect
number one they all believed that there
was an intelligence within them that was
giving them life that was that same
intelligence that I just talked about
and its function is for balance
restoration repair and regeneration
it is to maintain the body in its
balance and all of those biological
functions that you and I take for
granted are under the control of the
autonomic nervous system and the
autonomic nervos system is the automatic
nervous system and
so they all believe that there was some
intelligence that was giving them life
and they all believe that somehow
whatever you want to call that
intelligence they had to take time to
begin to make contact with with it and
to begin to give it a specific design
just like I
did and again once again surrender uh
their creation to this to this uh
automatic mind that that does the
healing for us the second thing they had
in common is on some level they began to
take responsibility for their own health
they started to say what was my state of
mind and body that may have contributed
to this disease whether it was cancer Ms
uh thyroid condition
what what was it uh that I had been
doing for the last 10 years or last 20
years that could have had an effect on
it what were the thoughts that I was
thinking what were the actions or habits
that I went unconscious to how did I
speak and they looked that certain
emotions that they lived by that they
may have mismanaged and they started to
become conscious of those unconscious
states of mind and body and this was an
important element because this was the
process of breaking the habit of being
themselves in other words they started
realizing that it was their unconscious
thoughts and feelings and and and
behaviors uh that had some uh effect on
their body and if they thought well if I
was thinking acting and feeling this way
if I start to change my thoughts if I
start to change how I speak how I act if
I could begin to give up certain
emotions that keep me connected to the
past and start feeling
differently would it begin to produce an
effect in my my body and and um they
began their own personal journey of of
changing from one state into another I
thought that was really important
because when I started studying this I I
realized that mind had the most dramatic
effect on the body and I went back to
school and started studying Neuroscience
in more detail and and I started to
discover that there is a very strong
correlation between how we think because
every thought we think produces a
chemical that chemical signals our body
to feel certain ways so then I said that
the hormones of stress cause us to
narrow our focus on the material world
because the arousal of those chemicals
causes us to pay attention to what's
causing it and we become very object
focused very materialistic because the
harmones of stress heighten our senses
and it causes us now to become more
aware of our body more aware of the
environment and more aware of time and
so when you've been doing your
meditation and I've asked you to take
your attention off your body and go from
somebody to a
nobody to take your attention off the
people in your life that you identify
with and to go from a someone to a no
one to no longer think about the objects
or things in your life from your cell
phone your computer your car to all the
elements that you are associating with
that are known you're going to go from
something to nothing if you're not
thinking about where you're sitting
where you live where you work where you
need to be you're going to go from
somewhere to nowhere and if you're not
thinking about the predictable future or
the familiar past you're going to go
from sometime to no time the act of you
practicing that and taking your
attention off of everything known we
could say that you are disinvesting all
of your attention and energy out of this
three-dimensional reality out of the
known and putting it on the unknown and
so you've been practicing becoming pure
Consciousness and it is the act of
opening your awareness when I ask you to
open your awareness into the Blackness
there's a reason for that because when
you go from a narrow Focus to a broad
Focus or an open focus and you take your
attention off the material world and put
it on nothing when you are no longer
focusing on the known and broadening
your focus and putting it on the unknown
you're putting your attention on nothing
in fact you are tuning in to energy and
frequency
now we learned that when people did this
properly when they broadened their focus
and they were sensing space the act of
sensing space caused them to stop
thinking and stop analyzing now when
they stopped thinking and analyzing they
stopped activating those circuits in
their brain that was causing their brain
to Fire incoherently and when they did
this properly when they were
sensing instead of thinking and
analyzing they began to change their
brain now let's talk about how they did
this I want to talk to you about a
simple understanding of brain waves when
you're living by the hormones of stress
and I said you're in that aroused State
your brain moves into a brain wave
pattern called high beta brain waves Now
High beta is that alarm state is that
emergency State that's the aroused state
but normal beta brain wave patterns is
like most of you right now you're
listening to me right now there's no
danger there's no threat and your
brain's job is to create meaning or
order between what's going on in the
outer world and what's going on in your
inner world and so your brain has a lot
to keep track of your senses plug you
into the three-dimensional reality think
about it if you couldn't see if you
couldn't hear you couldn't smell you
couldn't taste you couldn't feel you
would have no experience of the
three-dimensional reality so your senses
plug you into threedimensional reality
by the same
means when you're under the hormones of
of stress and there's an arousal the
senses are heightened and when that
occurs now now you got to pay more
attention you're more Vigilant so in
that kind of state where you're
processing information everything you're
seeing right now everything you're
listening to and hearing what you're
feeling what you're smelling your
brain's got a lot to keep track of and
and as it processes all this information
and you're relaxed in your environment
and you're awake your brain functions in
what's called beta brain wave patterns
if I said to you there's a test that you
have to take at the end of this uh
course your brain would perk up a little
bit more and you would move into what's
called mid-range beta in high range beta
it's three times as high as low range
beta and that's the emergency State and
in that high beta State that's when
you're shifting your attention from one
person to one problem to one object to
one place to one thing to another
meeting to another problem to your past
to your future and you activate these
circuits and the Brain fires
incoherently in a high beta State and
people get stuck in that state it's like
it's like driving your sports car in
first gear on the freeway I have worked
so hard in getting people to the point
where they can forget about themselves
and become nobody no one no thing
nowhere and no time people when they
finally get this when they finally
realize that when they're that they're
pure Consciousness and they're connected
to the field and then they start putting
their attention
on that frequency of Oneness and
wholeness and tune into it and pay
attention to it and stay present with it
and become more aware of it and
experience it and feel it moment after
moment after
moment how many how much of people's
waking day do they put their attention
on the field and how much do they put
their attention on matter I'd say 100%
of the time they put their attention on
matter now my students are connecting to
a greater frequency they know how to get
Beyond themselves they can sit for
extended periods of time they could lock
in they can experience I
watch if they're connecting to that
level of frequency called the quantum
field where they're experiencing
something cool something greater that
you can't experience with your senses as
you evolve and unfold deeper into it you
experience less separation and more
Oneness and wholeness and the more
connected you are to it the less
distance between you as a
Consciousness free willed individual and
the consciousness of the objective
unified field the closer you are to it
the shorter amount of time it's going to
take for it to appear in your life
because you're outside the you're
outside the fundamental rules of
Newtonian physics and 3D reality you're
you're changing the field and it changes
matter
instantaneously so now we're seeing it
happen in a shorter amount of time
because we're getting better at it we're
connecting to that field more and I know
this to be the case because when I
witness it in week-long
events I I know the moment I can tell
you when the energy shifts in the room
and now I know it's going to be fun now
I know get ready cuz the Miracles are
happening it'll happen in one week you
tell me how a tumor can disappear on a
person's thyroid not one not two you
tell me how a man with a stroke who's
been paralyzed in his arm and leg that's
in his 70s paralyzed for years now
lifting his arm above his head H how do
you explain that he he didn't do that
matter to matter he didn't change his
diet he didn't do physical therapy he
didn't try to have a good attitude and
think positively there was none of
that something in the field changed and
the pattern of that condition in the
field
changed so it is happening in a shorter
amount of time there is no
rule it's about the person's ability to
pay attention and to focus
to be greater than their body their
environment and time it's their
sincerity it's the engagement when they
go sit down and do it they're not doing
oh man I got to do this that's the wrong
attitude nothing's going to happen then
you get there like I'm going to connect
with the Divine this is going to be a
great day I'm going to keep my energy up
I'm not getting up until I feel like I'm
empowered that person's going to have a
rocking day they're going to have a good
day I think we've all experienced those
synchronicities where
you're thinking about something or you
have an intention and all of a sudden
you start to see reality kind of conform
itself around you in some way and you're
not going anywhere to get it uh somehow
it seems to be coming to you and there's
a very direct correlation between energy
and reality so when you start to
synchronize your energy to a possibility
that exists in the quantum field and you
have a coherent brain there's a very
very specific signal that we can send
out that's very very coherent and
clear and when we match that brain
coherence with heart coherence it is the
heart that acts as a magnet and draws
the experience back to us so the thought
being the electrical charge and the
feeling being the magnetic charge and
how you think and how you feel
broadcasts information into the quantum
field and I think whatever we broadcast
into the field is our experiment with
Destiny so we either create from the
field or we create from matter and if we
create from matter as bodies local in
space and time and three-dimensional
reality we have to move through space to
get what we want we have to move back
and forth to work and drive there uh to
manifest our dreams and in creating a
threedimensional reality takes time and
it takes energy sometimes people get so
lost in reality they forget what their
dreams were because there's too much
time between cause the thought and
affect the experience and that's what
separation does in three-dimensional
reality creating from the field and
getting Beyond yourself your
associations to everything physical and
known and being able to enter
through a small door the eye of the
needle the quantum field passing through
that eye of the needle as pure
Consciousness and connecting to a field
and teaching people how to create from
the field instead of from matter
connected to that unified field to
Source energy when they create from
source and they're Connected To Source
and source is the cause that creates
matter the effect if we create from
Source connected to it from the field
instead of from matter we don't have to
go anywhere now to get what we want we
begin to draw the experiences to it us
so by
combining heart coherence with brain
coherence now we have a Wi-Fi signal and
all we have to do is synchronize our
energy to some intention with some
emotion and tune in to the energy of the
future and the longer you're conscious
of this energy the more you draw your
future to you and if you keep practicing
it every day it's going to become
familiar to you and all of a sudden that
will be your natural energy and when you
change your energy
you change your life and the more
coherent the signatures
electromagnetically the more refined The
Experience uh we have when a person can
create the right type of energy the
right type of frequency from the field
and there's a vibrational match between
their energy and whatever they want in
their life all of a sudden they start
drawing experiences to them out of
nowhere they get the phone call hey I
got Synn it why because you're
synchronizing your
energy to a possibility in your life now
in the
quantum every thought has a
frequency so when a person has the
thought of their new job and they can
feel the frequency of that thought it
wouldn't be lack it wouldn't be
separation it wouldn't be frustration
the frequency of the thought of a new
job would create the feeling of euphoria
excitement
gratitude and thoughts tend to be
Electric in the quantum field and
feelings tend to be magnetic and now we
teach people how to create a Wi-Fi
signal when when they connect to the
field and they literally change their
energy the thought being the electrical
charge the feeling being the magnetic
charge and how you think and how you
feel is broadcasting energy
now there's a little bit more that has
to happen because you have to have
coherence in your brain the brain's got
to be very orderly and it's emitting a
field and the heart which it can do with
stress stress stress is static stress
you disconnect because all of your
attention is going on everything
physical and material and you're drawing
from this energy that's surrounding your
body and you're turning into chemistry
and now you're isolated you're separate
so we teach people how to get that brain
coherence going and their heart
coherence is going and coherence is
rhythm and Order and now you have this
wi-fi signal and when there's a
vibrational matcher you've synchronized
your energy to
synchronicity those serendipities those
coincidences those uh synchronicities
those opportunities start coming to
you now what's the cool part about that
it seems like there's a shortening of
time between the thought of what you
want and the experience of what you want
between cause and effect when we create
from the field instead of from matter if
we get really good at it then the
feedback that we experience in our life
is letting us know that we're doing
something correctly and when you start
getting the phone call or the email or
the introduction to somebody and you
scratch your head and you go oh my God
I'm the creator of my life and all of a
sudden the next day your
belief in what's
possible grow dramatically so when you
sit down to do it the next time you get
better at it and all of a sudden more
synchronicities start to happen and so
the side effect of it is uh and this is
what I'm proud of in our community is
that people do the work they don't they
don't do it because they have to do it
they do it because they don't want the
magic to end they want they want the
synchronicities to be happening now in
order for us to change the first step is
to become conscious of our unconscious
thoughts it's not just willpower no will
exists in the conscious mind but we have
to go into the operating system where
those programs exist right so when you
begin to become aware of your
unconscious thoughts you begin to notice
your automatic behaviors and you begin
to pay attention to how you're feeling
that fact in Neuroscience is called
metacognition the fact that you can
observe who you're being means you can
modify your behaviors modify your state
of being to do a better job in life and
so that's a skill that level of
awareness is a for Brin in activity and
um we can teach people how to do that so
when you begin to look at those states
of Mind and Body it begs the question if
you're observing the program it means
you're no longer the progam program
you're the Consciousness observing the
program and you begin to objectify your
subjective mind you become more
conscious and Consciousness then of
course is what really is the first step
to change how many people just cruising
along and all of a sudden things kind of
go the wrong way and the next thing you
know you're hating the person sitting
next to you and you don't even know
them you're hating life you want to quit
you hate me you know all of that stuff
and
look how many
times will you have to do that before
you realize that you don't want to do it
any longer H if you truly are astute and
sincere as a student
moment you start going there moment you
start coming back and you fatigue or you
can't reconnect again I want you to know
that you've come to the end of your
emotional belief you've come to the very
end of your neurological
Network and there's only one of two
things to do one is to return back and
pick something mundane that's going to
preoccupy your mind so you don't have to
go any further into the unknown
or the other is to just trust that you
can go a little further now if you trust
that you can go a little further then
all of those thoughts are just thoughts
in your head that you have to create
coherence around so if you stopped and
you said I am going to master this
moment forget about going anywhere doing
anything following the instructions I'm
just going to W work with my body to get
it back into the present moment and
continue to unfold back into possibility
if you turned that Battleship around
even slightly by executing a will that's
greater than that program and you are in
Hot Pursuit of your own
freedom and your brain and your
personality is beating you up I've had
those
moments and you know what it's David and
Goliath it has always seemed bigger than
me because I've given it so much of my
attention and so much of my energy it is
bigger than me but when I no longer pay
attention to it just
like not giving my power to it now I can
settle myself back into the present
moment and it's just the thought and I
examine that thought I look at it and I
become very familiar and conscious of it
I think we need a wakeup call and uh
stepping into a place where there is
uncertainty uh we are stepping from what
we know everything that's we know about
ourselves and our lives is being
challenged and we're stepping into the
unknown because every day it's more and
more difficult to predict uh what's
going to happen and if you can't predict
it it we're stepping out of familiar
territory and and I'd like to see this
uh as an opportunity for people uh to
break from the normal routine of their
lives I mean the entire world has been
disrupted from their normal personal
reality they're not going to the same
places and seeing the same people and
doing the exact same things at the exact
same time uh they're in a little mini
retreat uh in the comfort of their own
home and if change the idea of change
means to be greater than your
environment
uh to be greater than your body and to
be greater than time uh this is a
perfect opportunity to meet the
challenges in our lives uh from a
greater level of Consciousness as long
as you want to believe human beings have
been here is the game of survival I mean
100 years ago 150 years ago it wasn't
easy being human I mean you could die
from all kinds of things and famine and
predators and all of those things were
important elements to Keep Us Alive and
in fact fear was really adaptive you
don't walk up to a lion and pet it's
something tells you instinctually to not
do that right so that's very adaptive
and and when stress becomes
maladaptive it's a different story
because uh there when we react to
someone or something that's in our lives
but your your reaction whether it's a
lion or your mother-in-law doesn't
matter to to the body yeah because if if
it's a lion for the most part you're not
going to go 20% in you're not going to
go 40% if it's a l you're going to go
100% in right so but if it's your
mother-in-law and you're having the same
response what was once very adaptive
becomes very maladaptive right so it
turns out that as I said valid or
Justified the only person that that is
actually hurting is you because you're
knocking your body out of homeostasis
you're knocking your body body out of
balance health is balance health is
order so let's see if we could drive
this home really well you have three
types of stress physical chemical and
emotional physical stress is trauma
accidents injuries Falls chemical stress
is viruses bacteria blood sugar levels
uh hangovers toxins pesticides
pollutants that emotional stress is just
your reaction to everyone and everything
in your life well 75 to 90% of a person
that watch walks into a health care
facility in the Western World walks in
because of psychological and emotional
stress you could have the best diet you
could eat glutenfree vegan ketogenic
intermittent fasting with a little
macrobiotics on the side organic all of
that take all your vitamins take all
your all your supplements all your herbs
drink your teas do all of that you could
work out you could run you could do
Pilates you could do yoga what doesn't
matter get yourself chemically balanced
get yourself uh physically balanced but
if you haven't taken care of your
responses to everyone and everything in
your life your cells when you're living
in fear and perfectionism and
rigidity the signal to the cell is
there's a danger there's a threat and
the cell is going to take the signal and
the cell is going to make a protein from
a gene and if you keep signaling the
cell that there's danger in the
environment the cell is going to start
to downregulate a gene and make a
cheaper protein you have an enormous
amount of energy in your first center so
much life force that it can create
another human being that's a lot of
coiled up
energy and if energy then that all that
energy could make it to your
heart if it makes it to your heart it's
going to go to your brain but why not
direct it right to that mystical Center
to where some conditioning some Veil
some illusion is removed every time our
heart opens every time we
connect we are redistributing that
energy between these first three centers
we want the autonomic Nur system to
start balancing energy in these three
systems imagine the same passion you
have in your first center being
Amplified in your heart that's a lot of
love that is an enormous amount of love
and it and and and when it happens
sometimes it's almost like you have to
malfunction for a bit I mean it's
happened to me I I I don't function very
well because it's so big I have to I
need a moment I just need a moment to
let it in it's not something it's
big and if that energy makes it to the
heart and it can move right to those
crystals in the pineal gland and that
pathway of 146 begins to become open and
you're training your autonomic nervous
system to do it in time it'll
redistribute that energy amongst these
centers and you can ask my team leaders
uh a lot of them that have been doing
this and some of the people in this room
that have been to several week-long
events there that moment where it has it
starts to happen and it starts to move
and it's it's it's
wonderful but I want to emphasize that
this work is not about having
a a Kundalini or a pop or that's the
side effect I want you to understand of
energy moving I have had enormous
amounts of energy strike my brain and
nothing I was in Bliss my body did
nothing I have other times where there's
energy moving through my body and it's
trying to find a pathway and it does
weird things but it finally Works its
way out if I keep surrendering to it I
don't make that a habit cuz then I'm
stuck I'm I'm repeating the same thing
thing if it's happening over and over
again until it's done it usually changes
but we're not doing this work so you
could say oh I popped you didn't pop
what was up with you are you going to go
all in that's not what this is about
this is not about
competition and then the person who
hasn't po what am I doing
wrong and that's polarity and that's
Duality just remember there when there's
a change in Consciousness there's a
change in energy and people have the
mediation of energy when it's right for
them and I have had all kinds of crazy
things but what I realized is that if
I'm just doing the work to produce that
crazy thing and my life isn't looking
pretty good there's something missing
would you agree it has to be that you
this is practical that your that your
efforts are a Continuum there's no end
to it and the side effects that take
place with your body the side effects
that take place in the in the mystical
whatever that's that's
incidental to what you are doing to
create a better life to create a new
moment to create a new experience so
don't get caught up in the phenomenon
just get lost in the effort that's all
you have to do we've been primed over
time from thousands of years that the
unknown is a scary
place and so then by thinking the same
thoughts by making the same choice
voices by doing the same things that
create the same experiences that produce
the same feelings and emotions in
time and those emotions begin to
influence your very same
thoughts causes our biology to stay
exactly the
same and so we afford people new
information new knowledge new
understandings New Philosophy new Theory
and we Inspire them to make new
choices to begin to do new things and
break the old habit and relearn to
create new experiences and produce new
emotions and in just a matter of 4 days
people begin to upregulate genes that
begin to heal their body and change the
way their body functions just by
changing the way they think changing the
way they act and changing the way they
feel the problem is is that the brain
and body locked into the past
clinging to the known and familiar where
the body has been conditioned to be the
mind the moment a person decides to do
something differently or make a
different
choice they feel
uncomfortable because they've left the
known and they've left the familiar and
if the body has been conditioned to be
the
mind the animal the servant is now the
master and it wants to return back to
familiar territory and as we step out
out into the unknown and we feel that
discomfort the uncertainty not being
able to predict the next
moment the body begins to influence the
mind and we start to hear the same
thoughts and if we respond to that
thought that's hardwired in the brain
and we accept it we believe it we
surrender to it without saying is this
the
truth that same thought leads to the
same Choice which leads to the same
behavior which creates the same
experience and produces the same feeling
and the same emotion and the person says
this feels right to me but all it is is
that it feels
familiar and so the process of change
then is to become conscious of your
unconscious
thoughts and the more conscious you
become of your unconscious thoughts the
less you will go unconscious to them in
your waking day you say that we have to
master the concept of the present moment
what does that mean well there's so much
talk about the present moment and being
present in the power of now but um most
people
um they spend the majority of their life
uh 95% of the time either living by some
past emotion or some past habit or
anticipating the future based on the
past and so we're very rarely in the
present moment and and paying attention
is being present and it's a skill just
like anything else the more you practice
it the better you get at it so think
about it if feelings and emotions are
the end product of past experiences and
you can remember experien is better
because you can remember how they feel
if you wake up in the morning and you
have to search for The Familiar feeling
called you every morning and and that
feeling is unhappiness or frustration or
lack or insecurity or
fear the moment you get in touch with
that emotion you're starting your day
from the past because the emotion is a
record of the p past now if that emotion
is connected to memories that are mapped
neurologically in your brain of certain
people at certain places at certain
times with certain things then the
moment you feel that emotion you
associate that emotion with the past
memory then you're activating circuits
in your brain from the past so of how
you think and how you feel creates your
state of being and thoughts are the
vocabulary of the brain and feelings are
the vocabulary of your body then your
entire state of being is in the past and
most people are living in the past so
their body is their unconscious mind and
it doesn't know the difference between
an experience in their life that creates
an emotion and an emotion that they're
creating by thought alone so the body
it's exactly the same so those emotions
start driving people's thoughts and if
they can't think greater than how they
feel and feelings have become the means
of thinking and they believe that their
thoughts have something to do with their
Destiny then they're thinking in the
past so they're creating more of the
same life and by the same means if they
wake up in the morning and they come
back to their senses and they start out
with the same routine that they did
yesterday and they're going through a
series of routine habits of going to the
toilet making coffee eating breakfast
taking a shower driving the work the
same way then we could say for the most
part a person's future is nothing more
than a replication of the past and
they're not in the present moment and if
they keep doing that over and over again
that becomes a habit and a habit is a
redundant set of automatic unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions that's
acquired through frequent repetition The
Habit is when you've done something so
many times the body has become the mind
so for most people their body is
dragging them into a predictable future
and they're on autopilot based on what
they've done in the past and they've
lost their free will to a program in
order for us to change that reality we
have to change ourselves and be very
very selective about the information you
put into your brain uh and and make your
way first of all in in your life but at
the same time be open to new ways of
doing things new ways of thinking about
things uh I I just know that uh my close
group of friends and family um
everybody's challenged but uh they're
meeting that challenge um with with a
level of adaptability that says um
there's a solution we just we just have
to find it as as a community as a as a
culture so there a time for human beings
to really begin to wake up as a species
this is this is this is our moment I
want to give people um my greatest
understanding of the truth and numerous
opportunities to experience it I I want
to free their minds and open their
hearts with a simple formula that leads
them to a door right a door of unlimited
possibilities and I want the door to
show people that they are greater than
they think more powerful than they know
more unlimited than they could ever
dream and and I think by providing
people the science and taking it to a
point where it's understandable and
digestible changes a Consciousness it
changes a collective Consciousness uh
and and the testimonials are so
important because those 4 minute miles
are uh opportunities for people to to
believe in themselves again because
someone else is doing it right so so a
an emergent
Consciousness emergence in biology you
know those flocks of birds and the
schools of fish that are moving and
behaving in the same way there's no
leader in that process it's not a top-
down phenomenon everybody's leading
right so the coming of a new
Consciousness is it it can't be done uh
with the same Consciousness that's
created the problems that we have in the
world today you know and I think
no matter what you believe what I think
one thing that everybody is aware of
that something doesn't feel right you
know so so providing people with the
information the right
information that allows them to believe
in themselves and to believe in
possibility the side effect of all of
this is some of some really cool things
happening in medical schools where they
want to investigate what we're doing and
bring it into medical schools uh in
operating rooms now uh with navy seals
uh and and Veterans with trauma uh we
were working with um prisons and and
that was amazing actually a lot of yeah
a lot some great prisons and nobody's
talking to these people about why they
did what they did and what it really
means to change especially the ones that
are going to walk out into the same
environment you know so so um we're
working with lots of companies and
organizations around the world and
teaching them what true change means in
the Neuroscience of culture and how you
how you change a culture what it takes
to change a culture and what it takes to
change individuals so uh and then you
know then there's all kinds of fun
things like I'm I'm so invested in our
youth Community right now uh because
they are the seeds of the future and uh
they're going to have to resolve the
problems that were given to them from a
greater level of Consciousness and they
have to learn the principles of
leadership they have to ingrain that in
them and embody it uh they have to
understand their hormones they have to
understand values they have to
understand how to create from the field
instead of from matter so they can short
the distance between the thought of what
they want and the experience of having
it without having to work so hard to get
it and so we're investing a lot of uh my
time and energy into into our youth and
every event that we do we have over a
100 kids under the age of 25 that come
and and they're very passionate and I
and I I take time uh I go and see them
uh after I walk off the the stage or at
the end of of the day and I I talk to
them and and I say listen I don't care
if you go to school or you you you teach
yourself just get really really really
good at one thing just be just own it
just know that you know that you're the
best at it you do that you'll always be
valued we have three types of stress
that we we process in the physical body
we have physical stress that's like
trauma accidents injuries
Falls and then you have chemical stress
like toxins or pesticides or pollutants
or viruses or bacteria or hangovers or
nutritional
deficiencies and and then you have
emotional stress right and emotional
stress could be family tragedies car
accidents second mortgages single
parenting 401ks you know whatever that
is U but each one of those things
physical chemical or emotional U knock
the body out of homeostasis out of
Regulation out of balance being inate
capacity of the body when it's not
overstressed is that it wants to always
return back and regulate it wants to
return back to homeostasis it wants to
return back to order and that's kind of
inate in us that's an automatic process
that's running through the autonomic
nervous system so we could say the job
of the autonomic nervous system is to
create balance and Regulation and
homeostasis and it's automatic right and
that part of the brain sits under the
thinking neocortex and it's called the
chemical brain or the emotional brain or
the lyic brain or the mamelon brain and
it has all of those functions that make
blood sugar balanced hormone
levels digestive enzymes it's it's it's
it's doing what it can to take the body
and constantly repair it and regenerate
it and move it back into balance all of
those stressors knock the brain and body
out of balance and the innate mechanism
the stressor Bots brings it back to
balance well it just makes sense if you
keep knocking it out of balance over and
over again uh and you keep moving it out
of homeostasis that inbalance is going
to become the new balance and now you're
headed for disease because that
autonomic automatic system can't
regulate order in the body so a system
then is compromised the system breaks
down and so if
it's um physical trauma you know your
body can heal if you rest it if it's
chemical imbalance you take your uh
Pharmaceuticals or you take your neutr
cuticles your vitamins your minerals
your herbs you intermittent fast you you
eat a vegan diet you do anything you can
get the body back so that it's using
more energy for growth and repair so for
some
people digestion consumes more energy
than it act the process makes right so
they're in a state of constant um
diminishing returns right so uh when the
when the autonomic nervous system is out
of balance and the digestive system is
perceiving that there's a threat and
danger all the time in the outer world
the person's living in fear it's not a
time to digest right so that system is
compromised right so so then so then
they become very
sensitized to the foods they consume
because the response constantly from the
environment is weakening the organism
right so they're victim to the
environment so they're more susceptible
they'll have food allergies or whatever
it is so then the person then goes to a
diet where they
consume uh less foods that require more
energy to break down so it's like taking
a a camel in a desert that's fallen and
lifting all the packs off it getting it
back up and then slowly adding the packs
back on right so so people do things to
get the body back into chemical balance
and sometimes the the refining or
changing their diet in some way and
there's you know thousands of options
for that you got to feel good about it
and you got to believe in it um but the
big factor is emotional stress and
really for the most part 75 to 90% of
every person that walks into a health
care facility in the Western World walks
in because of psychological emotional
stress that's pretty much four out of
five people what's really causing their
health condition is that they're
emotionally stressed and emotionally out
of balance okay so what are the emotions
that are connected to the stress
hormones it's anger it's hatred it's
violence it's frustration it's
competition it's control it's judgment
it's Envy it's jealousy it's insecurity
it's fear it's anxiety it's worry it's
angst it's uh hopelessness it's
powerlessness it's guilt it's shame it's
unworthiness you know and psychology
calls these normal human States Of
Consciousness these are Altered States
Of Consciousness so our response to
someone or something in in our
environment or our response to our own
thought an image of what could happen in
the future a memory of the past could
actually cause chemicals to be secreted
from the brain it's crazy that causes
the body to actually believe it's living
in that same environment of fear or
danger what happens when the pineal
gland is activated your eyes are closed
and all of a sudden it starts picking up
frequencies that are faster than the
speed of light wavelengths faster than
the speed of light well Einstein said
equal mc^2 the ceiling of everything in
this three-dimensional reality is the
speed of light anything that travels
faster than the speed of light matter
turns into energy so now you're Going
Quantum so what happens then when the
pineal gland starts picking up
frequencies that are faster than the
wavelength of light now we're in the
quantum now that frequency is carrying
information and if the pineal gland the
research shows is a transducer it's
going to take that frequency that's
carrying information and turn it into a
profound visual experience and when it's
visual like that the hallucinogenic
chemicals that's created now you're not
just dreaming melatonin makes you dream
now you're really dreaming melatonin
gets the upgrade and you go lucid those
chemicals fit in the same receptor sites
and now you're in the dimension because
that's where all of your awareness is
and this world literally disappears now
what's the what's the what's the
importance of that experience enriches
the brain right experience produces an
emotion and we've seen people when they
hook up to this have rashes that they've
had their entire life disappear tumors
go away
um we've seen how do you explain that
well because the body is getting a
biological upgrade all like it's a
download exactly so then we see this
crazy switch go on in the brain and now
right on the top of the head on our
brain skins this area is very very
activated so energy is moving out as you
start to accelerate those those charge
molecules you're creating a magnet you
you're moving those charged molecules
and right to the top of the head and now
it's producing this very powerful
electromagnetic field a Taurus field now
once the pineal gland is signaled the
pineal gland sends a signal right to the
pituitary and now the pituitary has a
posterior aspect and the pituitary
begins to release two profound chemicals
oxytocin and vasopressin oxytocin is the
love chemical oxytocin signals nitric
oxide nitric oxide causes the arteries
in your heart and lungs right in this
area to begin to swell now you're
feeling an incredible Love For Life a
joy for existence you are so grateful
for the moment if you can turn on the
stress response just by thought Alone by
thinking about your problems and that's
the truth you can become addicted to
your own thoughts and if the long-term
effects of the hormones of stress push
the genetic buttons that create disease
your thoughts could make you sick and
then the question is if your thoughts
could make you sick can your thoughts
thoughts make you well and we're
actually discovering that that's
absolutely possible so then teaching
people then a little bit about how to
manage their emotional state and to
self-regulate I think is a great gift
for people because when they begin to
break an addiction to any emotion or the
conditioning of any emotion there's
going to be Cravings that go on just
like uh just like any addict there you
know and and you've many people overdose
and many people have bad trips and and
so when they start changing and the
body's craving uh those familiar
emotions the body starts signaling the
brain you know of memories or to think
certain ways and to make certain choices
do certain things crave certain
experiences just to feel that same
emotion and people say well this feels
right no that feels familiar that really
feels familiar and and many people will
tell the story of why they feel that way
based on some past experience and it's
usually not in the recent past it's
usually many years ago like a toxic
relationship or whatever that is and
so they're basically saying I had an
event in my life and since that event
I'm still living by the same emotion and
I haven't been able to change and
they'll tell the story of that past and
in Psychology the latest research on
memory shows that 50% of that story
isn't even the
truth they're they're they're making it
up because they don't have the same
brain as they had then and so then
people people are reliving a miserable
life they never even had just to excuse
themselves from changing and they
embellish the story so that it sounds
really hard to change so what is it what
is that point then for a person when
they say the only
person that this emotion of hatred or
anger or frustration or resentment the
only person that this is hurting is
me because those those chemicals are
downregulating genes and creating
disease and a person finally really
realizes that and they really decide to
change when they overcome the emotion
the memory without the emotion is called
wisdom and that's the name of the game
in three-dimensional reality now they're
ready for a new experience it's not it's
not reliving the past you don't need to
you don't need to talk about it all you
need to do is overcome the emotion when
you overcome the emotion you're free
from the past you can see it from a
greater level of Consciousness and
that's when a person so many times when
they truly change they'll say this we've
seen it over and over again they reach
that point where they finally break
through and they and some of them have
had some really difficult pasts they'll
say I would not want to change one thing
in my past because it brought me to this
moment that's the moment that past no
longer exists and they can look at their
betrayers and see it we all had to
happen for that moment and now they're
they're free they they no longer belong
to the past they belong to the the
future what is karma karma is a state of
being so if you're thinking the same way
and feeling the same way every day then
your reality is going to stay the same
so you break free of karma when you
overcome the emotion that you're
addicted to that keeps driving the same
thoughts and when you're no longer angry
or you're no longer hating or you're no
longer judging you're free so karma you
know we're punished for our sins we're
punished by our sins and the field has
no
opinion it's an objective endorser of
the state of being that you live in so I
don't believe in karmic contracts I
believe in Free Will yes and I believe
that we have the ability to change our
state of being by changing the way we
think and the way we feel and if you
retire those emotional states and memory
without the emotional charge is called
wisdom and that's the name of the game
and now you're not anchored to your past
any longer because your emotions keep
you connected to your past and your your
past will be your future the moment you
move into the present moment and you
break free from the chains of those
addictions emotionally the soul gains
wisdom and now it's time to create a new
future so I think people get caught up
while I'm going to do the right thing so
I get good karma there's no God with a
laptop up there keeping score of what
how you're doing it's not how it works
people who give for the sake of giving
because they're in love with life those
are the Saints and the mystics they're
not they're not doing it because they're
they're trying to gain some extra points
in the future that's this is It's a
limited view of a a reality a reality
that's created by people who don't
understand that there's this field of
intelligence is a loving intelligence
and an intelligent love and it endorses
who we're being do we need to have an
intent in this kind of process or create
an intention or let's talk about that
because many people's like there's a a
delicate balance I think between
intention and surrender uhhuh intention
is getting clear on what you want right
but if we're experiencing
separation then when we over intend
we're trying right and so then you're
trying to create something from lack
that's when you over
intend surrender is like trusting in the
outcome right but if you over surrender
you're lazy and lethargic right you're
not doing anything so it's a Razor's
Edge so so the per the person who is
involved in activating those latent
systems that's their intent so I now
know that the more people will
understand what they're doing and why
the how gets easier so we provide the
knowledge the science the information so
that they can begin to reason what
they're about to do and they repeat it
to the person next to them as they talk
about it they're building a model of
understanding they're preparing
themselves neurologically for the
experience so so the intention then is
to activate those latent systems M and
all the things we're doing we're opening
our heart drawing that energy to the
brain surren entering into the field
activating that gland they understand
what the outcome is going to be but
there are other intentions that are not
the primary intention because they've
gotten very clear on who they want to be
in their future part of the knocking on
the door their future is that they're
whole and they're healthy but they're
not going into the experience for
wholeness and health they're going into
the experience to have the mystical
moment so as they begin to dream their
yeah exactly you have to give up every
aspect of yourself for something greater
you got to go from selfish to selfless
you got to go from somebody to nobody to
everybody from someone to no one to
everyone from something to nothing to
everything from somewhere to Nowhere to
everywhere from sometime to no time to
every time that is the Quantum the
three-dimensional reality is really just
about your body in an environment in
linear time so the hormones of stress
cause us then to be become very local in
space and time and when you turn on that
response you're drawing from this
invisible field of energy of light and
information that's surrounding your body
this vital life force and you're turning
it into chemistry and when you do that
the field around your body shrinks a
little bit you become more matter less
energy more particle less wave and now
you start trying as matter trying to
change matter to force outcomes do that
for an extended period of time then you
don't have any energy to heal you don't
have any energy to create a new future
you you've you've actually tapped your
body's life force its
reserves so then what's the solution
what have we found that a part of the
formula is shifting from what we call a
convergent focus a narrow focus on
something
material to begin to broaden your focus
close your eyes and instead of narrow
your focus open your focus or broaden
your focus or what's called a Divergent
focus is opening your focus out
convergent Focus focusing in so as you
begin to open your
focus uh you start going against that
habit and people do it for a few seconds
and then they go back to the habit but
if you keep teaching them how to do that
uh and they keep opening their awareness
to space to nothing material the act of
sensing and tuning in to
frequency causes them to stop analyzing
and thinking when you're sensing you're
not analyzing you're sensing you're
feeling and when you do that if you're
thinking less you start slowing down
your brain waves and you
stop kicking that analytical mind into
gear so the whole purpose of meditation
is to get beyond the analytical mind and
what separates the conscious mind from
the subconscious mind is the analytical
mind and if you can't change your brain
waves and get beyond that analytical
mind you're separate from the operating
system where all those subconscious
programs exist so then as you begin to
open your awareness and you're thinking
less
as you shift your brain waves from beta
as it slows down you start moving into
what's called Alpha Brain Wave patterns
and now your inner World tends to be
more real than your outer world and
you're not thinking as much and there's
no critic in your head no voice in your
head talking to you instead your brain
is creating in pictures and images and
it's slowing down would you say that
Consciousness and the state of your
being is more important than the high
quality food you're ingesting well you
have three types of stress you have
physical stress you have chemical stress
and you have emotional stress so there's
three ways to create balance in the body
physically chemically and emotional you
exercise you do yoga you breathe you you
take care of your body you don't ovat
you eat balanced you know you sleep and
you know you take care of your emotional
addictions and your stress levels and
you manage them and that allows the body
to move back to balance stress is when
the body's knocked out of balance but so
much emphasis is put on diet sometimes
when people people are going to eat the
vegetarian raw foods and food combined
properly and but the person is living in
such a state of anxiety that the body is
the unconscious mind is believing that
it's being chased by a lion all day long
or there's a predator around the corner
and in that state there's no time it's
not a time to digest when you're being
chased by a lion it's time to run so
there's no energy to the digestive
organs to even assimilate the most
organic food and then if you're
emotionally feeling like a victim or
some other emotional state and that
emotion is signaling the gene you're
going to take all of that organic food
and turn it into the organic protein of
victimization you're going to be an
organic victim I mean that's just a
scientific fact
so I believe in taking care of your body
I believe in not overeating I believe in
eaing or organic food I mean I grow all
my own food I you know we have an
amazing uh Ranch that that we believe in
that kind of uh level of Consciousness
uh uh but I I think that people get
caught up you know they're they get so
rigid in certain ways that I think they
miss the bigger picture and um you know
every type of stress if you think about
it ends up as emotional or psychological
stress you break your leg it's a you
have a discarnation that's a physical
stress that physical stress creates uh a
pain and that creates chemical stress
and that chemical stress creates
emotional stress which creates chemical
stress and then you're psychologically
more stressed it always ends up as
psychological stress so teaching people
how to regulate and short refractory
period of their emotional reactions to
things in their life managing their
inner world is where the body can
recalibrate that's when the body can
move back to balance so I think there
has to be a bigger picture that has to
be drawn what are some of in the formula
for example the things that you teach to
help take this incredible knowledge and
put it into practice I think the most
important part is to experiment to be
curious to to really see you know most
people they respond to their outter
environment and their outter environment
is really controlling the way they think
and feel and I say say David why are you
upset today it's because of that person
or circumstance what you're really
saying is that some person or
circumstance is actually controlling the
way I feel and the way I think well most
of the time our response to the
environment because of the stress
hormones actually weakens the organism
that goes a step further though when you
think about your problems you produce
the same stress response as if it was
happening your body so objective it's
believe it's it's living in that
environmental State and it's that
constant attack and that response
uh from the environment that begins to
downregulate genes and weaken the immune
system so the fundamental question is if
you can turn on the stress response by
thought alone the long-term effects of
those chemicals U push the genetic
buttons that create disease then that
means our thoughts can make us sick so
then if our thoughts can make us sick is
it possible that our thoughts can make
us well so when a person is less
responsive less of a victim to their
environment their environments no longer
controlling the way they think and feel
then the next fundamental question is if
I change the way I think and feel should
it change my environment now that's
going from a victim in your life to
being a creator of your life and that's
the experiment and everybody should
believe that they are the creator of
their life we teach people uh some basic
tools uh the formula really is about 10
years of research that we were able to
say you could actually change your brain
waves and create more order in your
brain the the dissonance and incoherence
that's created when when we're under
stress really causes the brain to
compartmentalize and fire out of order
and so we demystified the process after
looking of at thousands of scans to be
able to say you could actually make your
brain work better and you can do that in
a very short amount of time so in order
to create a new future to change
something in your life nothing changes
in your life until you change that's the
that's the story right so then the
question is okay is in order for me to
create something new I'm going to have
to combine a clear intention that's a
function of the brain and the mind
that's a a process that you can get
better at and you got you got to combine
that with an elevated emotion and that
means then you can't wait for your
healing to feel grateful you can't wait
for your new relationship to feel love
you can't wait for your wealth to feel
abundance you know that's that's the old
model of reality of cause and effect in
fact we're going to teach people
actually how to feel the emotion before
it happens and when you combine that
clear intention with an elevated emotion
that's going to require your heart to
move into balance and move into order
and turns out that's a skill too that
you can practice so then when you
combine those two elements so that clear
intention with the elevated emotion and
you can sustain that for a period of
time the coherence in the brain the
coherence in the heart actually act like
a WiFi signal you you're starting to put
out a Broadband spectrum of frequency
and energy that causes you to feel
connected to something and now you're no
longer trying to get something done or
waiting for something in your outer
World to Change to take away the
emptiness or lack you're feeling because
you don't have the experience yet if
people can actually feel the feelings of
the emotions before the experience
happen happens they wouldn't be looking
for it because they would feel like it
already happened right so we teach
people how to sustain these states and
if they can the side effect of that is
that you start seeing synchronicities in
your life those serendipities those
coincidences those opportunities that
you're no longer going anywhere to get
them and you're not trying to control
the outcome or Force the outcome or
fight for the outcome or predict the
outcome or or compete for it that's
that's when we're matter trying to
change matter when you synchronize your
energy to a possibility in your life and
you start seeing those synchronicities
in your life now when you start seeing
those opportunities occurring you're
going to start paying attention to what
you've been doing and do more of it and
you go then from being the victim of
your life to being the creator of your
life and the cool part about it is you
don't have to go anywhere to get it
somehow out of nowhere it seems to come
to you the emotions that people
primarily hold on to are the emotions of
stress the the anger and the aggression
and the fear and the anxiety and the
pain and suffering the hopelessness the
powerlessness those are all driven by
the hormones of stress what most people
don't know is that when we have the
stress response and we're reacting to
something there's a rush of energy
because from a from a adaptive
standpoint that's how we survive we
would see a threat in our environment we
get a burst of energy and then we would
mobilize all this energy to protect
ourselves the HBA reaction system
exactly so then what what was
once highly adaptive mhm has now become
very maladaptive get rid of the program
because the maladaptive program means
that if you're sitting on your the the
porch of your house and you're fretting
over which employee to Fire and you know
one really deserves the job but the boss
likes the other one and you have to go
deliver the bad news and that person
doesn't uh has two kids and his wife is
has cancer and you have to make that
choice now you're turning on the stress
response just by thought alone there's
no longer a lion chasing you you're
thinking about some worst case scenario
and you're making thought more real than
anything else and when that happens the
body does not know the difference
between the
experience of being chased by a lion
that produces the emotions of stress and
the emotions you're fabricating by
thought alone to the body it's being
knocked out of balance just by thought
alone now here's the
kicker we can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone and the
absolute biological fact as the hormones
of stress begin to push the genetic
buttons that create disease then by pure
reason we could say our thoughts make us
sick M well then the question is if our
thoughts make us sick can our thoughts
make us well we teach meditation three
ways to become familiar with your old
self and to become familiar with your
new self that's what the word meditation
means familiarization to become familiar
with so we use that model for change so
slow your brain waves down and get
beyond your analytical mind is
meditation and you teach your body how
to do that and we've discovered a
formula that that simply makes it very
easy for people to do it you practice it
you'll get good at it just like anything
else you practice so so to get beyond
the analytical mind there's another way
to reprogram ourselves and then
meditation is really about getting
beyond your body or disconnecting from
your body disconnecting from your
environment and forgetting about time
and that is that eye of the needle where
we begin to make the most significant
changes so we're data driven you know
we're really looking to see what it is
and and when we see uh brains respond in
the same way it helps me enormously to
teach the material better and so the
more people understand what they're
doing and the more they understand why
they're doing it the more naturally the
how becomes easier and nothing is left
to conjecture if nothing is left to
Superstition or Dogma or even in
spiritual you know traditional words you
science says the Contemporary language
to demystify that process you need give
new people numerous times to overcome
themselves and numerous times to connect
sooner or later you'll start watching
transformation right before your eyes
and so one of the cool things that we've
discovered is that we have so much
compelling data to suggest that you're
greater than you think more powerful
than you no more unlimited than you
could ever dream we have compelling data
that suggest that your nervous system is
the greatest pharmacist in the world
that it makes drugs that work better
than any drug in a drugstore a drug
study is about 18 to 25% cause and
effect causality our data is between 75
and 85% cause and effect this is a
person creating their own Pharmacy of
anti-inflammatories their own Pharmacy
of anti-carcinogenic chemicals their own
Pharmacy of uh pain relievers who were
seeing this over and over again
so we have this incredible data that
says that this is no longer
pseudoscience this is the real this is
really science the side effect of a
person's
transformation is has changed my belief
in what's possible I have seen people
stand on the stage with stage four
cancers that were in every single organ
in their body that metastasize and and
they have no sign of cancer in their
body and we have data that suggests that
you put the blood of an advanced
meditator and an uterine cancer cell a
pancreatic cancer
cell 70% of the mitochondrial function
in the cancer cell is diminished the
mitochondria is the energy packets of
the cell it's taking energy out of the
cancer cell works perfect with what
we're seeing with uh uh the testimonials
uh that that people are telling around
the world we've seen blind people see
we've seen deaf people here we've seen
uh people with spinal cord injuries walk
again we've seen uh ALS change we've
seen all kinds of unbelievable health
conditions change by a person simply
changing the way they think the way they
act and the way they feel I'm interested
in
unifying as many different branches of
science in a very simplistic
way that I give people tools that they
have within their reach to prove to
themselves that they're greater than the
think more powerful than they know more
unlimited than they could ever dream all
I offer people is my greatest
understanding of the
truth and numerous opportunities to
experience it nothing more I want to
free their
minds and open their hearts with a
simple formula leads them to a door a
door of unlimited possibilities and I've
come to learn that I can only show them
the door uh they're the ones that have
to walk walk through it I never thought
coherence would be anything that I would
be studying right I mean I never thought
that at
all but when I started really looking at
the physics behind
coherence you know there's an invisible
field of energy that we are sitting in
right now that that we are unaware of
and if we're unaware of it it doesn't
exist for
us we experience separation because of
that the more we become aware of that
invisible
field the more we're not our bodies the
more we're not aware of our environment
the more we are less aware of
time there's a door that we can pass
through to the quantum field is pure
Consciousness so we've done thousands
and thousands of brain scans in addition
we partner with Heart maath Institute
and we measure heart coherence and heart
coherence of course is uh a function of
a person's ability to sustain elevated
emotional states that when we live in
fear we live in anxiety we live in
resentment uh frustration impatience the
heart beats very incoherently when we're
living by those survival States those
stressful
States and when we teach people to
combine a clear intention which is a
function of a coherent brain with an
elevated emotion which is a function of
a coherent
heart that when you start feeling
gratitude when you start feeling
inspired when you start feeling the love
for Life The Joy for
existence turns out the heart starts
beating more coherently and the Heart
producing a measurable magnetic field
that energy that frequency carries
information so we teach our students to
use that energy to then create create a
future or to change their health because
that energy will carry a thought or an
intention or a message and when that
occurs they begin to change their own
expression of electromagnetic signature
around their body and so when we change
our energy we change our health and we
change our
life so we've done thousands and
thousands of HRV measurements and what
we do in our workshops is we give uh our
students uh a HRV device to wear on
their chest with a lead and we're
measuring their heart and how it
functions over a 24-hour period of time
and when they walk into a meditation and
they sit down they start the process we
want to see if they're able to sustain
that state for an extended period of
time and then when we can see the
changes that they make then we know uh
we can tell them what you're doing is
actually correct keep doing it or if
they're not doing it well enough we can
give them more information on how to do
it better and so our students then are
uh combining that clear intention with
an elevated emotion is beginning to
create changes in their biology I wrote
a book called uh evolve your brain uh
and then there was uh documentary called
what the bleep do we know and that
became a very popular uh documentary and
open people's mind up to what was
possible as human beings but when I was
um
touring with the with the scientists and
researchers uh that were in this movie I
started paying attention to the
questions people asked when we were
doing these seminars around the world
and they kept
asking um okay uh our thoughts have some
effect on our bodies our thoughts have
some effect on our minds our thoughts
have some effect on our lives okay uh
how do you do it and I thought that was
a great question the second thing is if
your personality creates your personal
reality in order to create a new
personal reality you have to change your
personality well how do we change and
why is it so hard to change and I
thought that was a really great question
the third question was what do you do I
remember the moment I watched a woman
with Ms that was confined to a
wheelchair for about 10 years after one
meditation stand up uh out of that
wheelchair and start to walk around
actually she was dancing around and I
realized right in that moment that
something happened to that person in
other words what happened biologically
what happened scientifically was there a
uh was there a a change in gene
expression was there a change in mind
what did she do that began to affect her
body and all of a sudden I just could
not go back to business as usual it was
there was too much uh uh too many
questions that I had asked and too much
evidence now because we started seeing
it more and more uh as we kept teaching
these
workshops and I thought okay uh now
we're starting to see these changes
let's organize a team of scientists and
researchers and begin to do some
measurements and so I wrote another book
called breaking the habit of being
yourself and that was more of the how to
teach people the the beginning stages of
how to change how to unlearn and relearn
how to break the habit of the old self
and reinvent the new self how to prune
synaptic connections and Sprout new
connections uh how to deprogram and
reprogram unfire and unwire refire and
rewire to lose your mind and create a
new one how how do we
unmoral eegs we we were taking
measurements of people that would come
to our events go through four days of
training or four and a half days of
training and then we would scan their
brain at the end and we wanted to see
that changes weren't just in their mind
that they were in fact in their brain
and then we started doing something
really important is we started measuring
people's brains in real time during a
meditation to see any fundamental clues
that could help us understand their
inner workings and we gained so much
knowledge about the process of change
and transformation we measured heart
rate variability we know that when a
person person is resentful when they're
impatient when they're frustrated their
heart beats very differently compared to
when they're in a state of gratitude or
Joy or inspiration or feeling care and
kindness we measured the energy of the
room we wanted to see if a collective
group of people could begin to affect
the environment around them the energy
in the room we measured the energy
fields around their body we measured the
energy centers of their body because we
did certain things to influence those
individual energy centers that are under
the control of the autonomic nervous
system we measured gene expression uh we
now know that you can change your gene
expression in 4 days we measured immune
regulation we wanted to see if people
gave up those emotions of stress and
went into more elevated emotions if it
would strengthen their immune system if
it gave them more energy for growth and
repair we measured telome lengths we
wanted to see if people could sustain
the proper homeostasis and balance and
self-regulate and do meditations every
day for 60 days only five out of seven
days a week if it began to change their
telr the the little shoestring caps on
the end of the DNA that determine your
biological age we saw that three out of
four people that did their meditations
on a regular basis uh changed their
genetic Destiny they changed their
future and if you asked me over 10 12
years ago if I thought that I would be
seeing the changes that I'm currently
seeing uh presently I probably would
have told you maybe once or twice but um
there's been a huge shift there has been
a significant change there's been a
movement and there's a momentum of
people that are beginning to understand
what they're doing and why they're doing
it broadening your awareness starts to
create brain coherence and when the
brain starts functioning in a more
orderly and coherent way and it begins
to synchronize and those different
compartments of the brain start working
together there comes a moment where the
two hemispheres of the brain start to
synchronize into balance and the union
of polarity the union of opposites the
union of Duality is called wholeness and
now we are creating from wholeness
instead of from lack or separation and
this is where it gets exciting because
when a person does this
properly and they can practice it our
research shows that people can change
their brain waves in one second in 4
seconds in 5 seconds and 12 seconds and
13 seconds and 19 seconds why because
they understand the process of getting
Beyond themselves so why is that
important for you because up until this
point whether you know it or not you
have been the process of practicing
brain coherence the first part of the
formula and
so when you open up your awareness in
your next meditation I'm going to ask
you as if you had no eyes no ears no
body to feel to smell to taste as if you
were just an awareness I'm going to ask
you to sense this Blackness and I'm
going to ask you to sense its depth I'm
going to say how far can your awareness
go into endless space and all I want you
to do is sense its infinite depth I'm
going to ask you to become aware that
there's infinite Blackness on both sides
of you and all I want you to do is
broaden your focus and to sense it to
feel it to stay connected to it and the
act of opening your awareness in sensing
space slows your brain waves down I'm
going to ask you to become aware that
there's Infinite Space behind you and
the act of sensing that Infinite Space
behind you causes your brain to start to
fire more orderly we've measured this
thousands of times and as if you were
just an awareness in that Blackness I'm
going to say to you now it's time to
become nobody no one no thing nowhere
and no time and take your attention off
of everything known into invested into
the unknown and like investing into a
bank account the longer you linger in
the unknown the more you create
possibilities in your life and if you
find your mind returning to your body to
your pain to your drives to your
emotions to your habits to thinking
about certain people or objects or
places or things in your known
predictable reality to thinking about
the familiar past or the eventual future
simply become aware that your attention
is on the known investing back into this
three-dimensional reality stop relax
return back to the present moment and
unfold back into possibility into the
Blackness could you speak about the
neurophysiology of forgiveness think
about Frozen circuits
Frozen circuits are hardwired
circuits the more profound the insult to
the
person that is connected to a strong
emotion the more the brain freezes
circuitry the more we think about the
experience the more we fire and wire the
circuits in our brain yes or no and the
more we remember the event the more we
produce the emotions that are associated
with it and we're conditioning the brain
and body further into the past yes or no
yes and it you keep doing it enough
times it's no longer conscious that
you're holding a grudge it's no longer
conscious that you're stuck it's now
you're seeing everybody through the lens
of that experience and everybody's a
betrayer everybody can't be trusted
everybody is that same person you're
you're
overlaying the memory of re of your
experience into reality you're not
seeing it the way it is you're seeing
that person wearing the mask of the last
person that's the lens that we're
perceiving reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion and the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened are you with me
still yes and so then the person says
I'm not that person and you say oh no I
know I just had this event in my past
and I'm sorry and then it's excusable
but then here it happens again and
there's nothing wrong with this we all
do it it's just how do we overcome it so
then you're sitting and doing the
work and you're you're moving energy up
those centers you're releasing the life
force into your
brain you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
you're unfolding as nobody no one no
thing nowhere in no time and the
identity and the personality is gone
energy is going to move it's got to it's
going to follow the
path you're opening your heart once it
gets to your heart it's going to make
its way all the way up and when you feel
love and compassion when you feel true
true kindness and care it's hard to hold
a grudge are you with me still yes so
then from
a quantum physics point of
view you have that person always in the
back of your mind right you have the
event and the memory rolling around back
there because the very thing that you
don't want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally are you with
me still so then from a Quant
perspective you are actually as a
creator of reality holding yourself
hostage because of that person and you
are holding them hostage because of that
experience and you have an energetic
Bond that's connecting you to them and
you're sharing the same energy and so
then you're using each other to reaffirm
whatever that energetic agreement is are
you with me still so then when you
forgive someone it's because there's
been a strong change in your emotional
state cuz the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person and so then once
you start lowering the volume to that
emotion and the body starts liberating
energy and you're calling your energy
back to you because the lower the volume
of the emotion the less you're going to
pay attention to that person there comes
a moment where there's a snap there's a
release the energy is broken and once
it's broken now all of a sudden you free
yourself and you free them and this has
happened to me in my life that people
show up 10 years later completely
changed and
so humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because they had transformed and
and I let them go so then
forgiveness from a Quantum perspective
and a neurophysiological perspective is
just taking your attention off them
that's all it is and when you start
getting happy with
yourself and you start feeling those
elevated emotions cuz you're striving
for that you wouldn't trade this for The
Grudge you were holding because this
feels too good physical balance okay
let's talk about that what do you want
to do uh intermittent uh
interval training you want to do yoga
you want to do um Pilates um you want to
do sprinting you want to do running you
want to do weights whatever it is get
your body more physically balanced and
physical balance has to do with f
strength flexibility and endurance and
get those three in Balance right so you
want to do acupuncture chiropractic
massage whatever it is that you want to
treat your body to to honor it in that
way way get it back into physical
balance
and there's no doubt in any in any one
of these areas you're going to have to
stretch yourself outside of what you
think you can do because that's the only
way you're going to change yes so just
when you think you've had enough then go
a little bit more stretch yourself out
that way without hurting yourself but do
it with intention do it with assigning
meaning to why you're doing that
activity get the greatest value out of
it works better when you do yes don't
resist and get into it face off with
whatever it is the pain the limitation
whatever and just Mark your progress and
have it be something that you mindfully
want to improve on do that and your body
will get stronger get more flexible and
have more endurance okay so um take care
of your body chemically you know get a
blood test I don't know do do do
whatever you need to do to get it
chemically back in the balance if you're
if you're having these symptoms uh then
you're going to have to maybe start
eliminating certain things and making
different choic does that mean that
stuff is bad no it means you're out of
balance and it's bad for you and don't
make it a thing like you have to do it
forever just understand why you're doing
it so take your nutrients and your
vitamins and your minerals and
understand why you're taking those
things and do that with the intention
right so meaning behind you'll get a
greater outcome this is a mature group
of
people and you we are pushing you
outside of everything that's known I'm
asking you to get up early in the
morning I'm asking you to make different
choices I'm asking you to do different
things I'm asking you to have new
experiences I'm asking you to feel
different emotions and when you strive
from the old personality to the new
personality the moment you're not
thinking the same way or making the same
choices the moment you're not
demonstrating the same behaviors or
reaffirming the same experiences and
emotions you've just left the known and
you're in the and you're uncomfortable
yes or no now you're uncomfortable
because you can't predict your future in
the next moment that's why you're
uncomfortable you don't know what I'm
going to do what we're going to do next
and that to the program is a little bit
disturbing and I said when we started
this event on Monday evening you learn
the most about
yourself and the people in your life
when they're
uncomfortable because what's going to
happen is a program is going to try to
fit in there to try to control try to
predict try to fight for an outcome and
all I'm asking you to do is this week
stay in the present moment stay outside
of your comfor Zone long enough for
something unknown to land in there but
if you keep expecting something to
happen the next moment you are
overlaying a known on an unknown and
you're going to close the door to
possibilities the quantum field is an
invisible field of energy of frequency
of information that connects and unifies
everything physical or material and its
signature is order it is wholeness it is
Oneness and as people don't know this as
they're sensing nothing but space they
begin to entrain their autonomic nervous
system to start to unify with that
unified field and all of a sudden the
nervous system starts functioning more
orderly
and then all of a sudden we started
seeing certain people feeling so relaxed
feeling so safe feeling so
connected that their body felt safe
enough to relax even more and the body
starts to fall asleep into a light sleep
and the person is awake and that's
called Theta and in Theta now a very
slow brain wave pattern if the body is
asleep in the mind is awake and we've
conditioned the body to be the Mind
habitually and emotionally that's the
moment the body is no longer the mind
and the door between the conscious mind
and the subconscious mind is wide open
to information and this is when we can
rewrite a program this is when we can
lay down a new track this is when we
could begin to rehearse a new program so
that we begin to subconsciously change
our unwanted habits and
behaviors and we have great measurements
of people in that Theta state where they
are reprogramming their nervous system
and reprogramming their brain and body
into a new future I think anybody who is
alive right
now who is engaged in
life has noticed a
quickening uh taking place in other
words everybody feels like more things
are happening in a shorter amount of
time so there's an acceleration and time
is a construct in our mind
there's no circuitry there's no Hardware
in our brain to be able to understand
time it's a construct based on our past
and how we predict the
future
but
information is so readily available in
our world right now that in an age of
information ignorance is a
choice so you don't need an authority to
gain information any longer you don't
need a priest you don't need a governor
you don't need a doctor you don't need a
teacher you can access information at
your
fingertips so then as you begin to
discern the information with discernment
the proper and right
information you begin to develop some
type of empowerment because all of a
sudden you're seeing
possibilities that you never saw before
without that information so you wake up
you become more aware so the knowledge
creates awareness awareness creates
Consciousness Consciousness and energy
are connected so there's a change in
energy globally going on with the world
now that that that knowledge and that
change of energy has effects on
paradigms that are no longer a
vibrational match with that new level of
Consciousness so you see a political
systems unraveling you see economics
economic systems unraveling they're unsp
spiring they're unraveling they can't
sustain themselves with this new energy
you see
journalism the environment education
religion uh uh medicine it's all
unraveling because something greater has
to come as a result of a change in
Consciousness now no victims here
because you and I
negotiated from a soul level to be here
at this time this is the time we've been
waiting for this is this is where it's
happening in the Milky Way this is it's
happening here because there's a true um
Coming of a new Consciousness it's not
one person that's
coming it's a group it's a collective
Consciousness that's emerging and
emergence is uh one mind one
heart and the way you control people is
you give them misinformation based on
emotions you control people by
controlling their emotions and media and
television and advertisement is a great
seduction that people can watch a uh the
news and get really angry then change
the channel and watch a football game
and get very excited then change the
channel and uh watch a sitcomm and laugh
and change the channel and watch a drama
and and you can change your emotional
state because of
technology so then it means then most
people are relying consciously or
subconsciously on things outside of them
to make them feel a certain way and so
my interest is is to provide the proper
content of information scientifically to
people so that they reason that this is
actually possible then to give them the
opportunity to experience that
philosophy and get their behaviors to
match their intentions as many ways as I
can now if I do that properly people are
going to have new experiences the
experiences are going to change the
circuitry in their brain learning makes
connections but experience enriches
connections the end product of an
experience is an emotion so when you
start feeling worthy when you start
feeling a love for yourself when you
start feeling A Love For Life when you
start feeling truly grateful the moment
you feel that emotion you're teaching
your body to understand what your mind
is understood if I was to take off my
coaching hat and put it on you Dr Joe
and you gave people one assignment to
take action on today what would it be
well I think probably the first thing I
would have people do is to really decide
what they want in their life I mean
that's the first step decide what what
your future could look like and and get
clear on what that vision is and write
down the specifics of what you want in
your life whether it's with your family
or your career or with a relationship or
whatever it is and and get get clear on
what that vision is of yourself in the
future and then write down the
emotions of how you'll feel when it
happens will you be joyful will you be
enthusiastic IC will you be filled with
energy will you love your life and and
be in a state of gr constant state of
gratitude and now you have a clear
intention and elevated emotion and every
morning when you start your day before
you open your eyes and reach for your
cell phone and check your WhatsApp and
your texts and your Facebook and your
Twitter and your Instagram and your
LinkedIn and your emails before you plug
yourself back into your same familiar
World sit there and get very clear on
what that future will be like begin to
emotionally embrace it before it happens
and if you do that properly you're
moving into a new state of being and
then at certain points in your day just
break and ask yourself how you're doing
how am I doing am I doing well am I
losing it am I falling from grace and
then recalibrate and and at the end of
your day ask yourself how you did and
and if you keep changing your state of
being over and over again your state of
being is your personality and your
personality creates your personal
reality and when you start seeing those
changes in your life and those
synchronicities the energy and the
excitement of the surprise of that event
is going to inspire you to create again
and I think that's how we move from
victims in our lives to creators of Our
Lives I believe that it's not matter
that is emitting a field I think it's
the field that creates matter so when
you change the field you change matter
and the science behind that is very
supportive so my ability to articulate
it my research that I've done since then
and the studies that I've done uh in
additional education has helped me to be
able to put together a formula uh and
that
formula uh in this present time is is
producing very dramatic changes in
people's lives and health and let's do
gratitude appreciation kindness uh
thankfulness and let's let's start
self-regulating and and we put heart
rate monitors on them to make sure that
they were doing it at uh 10 minutes a
day for 3 days in a row right three
times a day at the end of 3 days 3 and
1/2 days we remeasured everything their
IGA levels went up
50% 50% that's that means that their
body was really beginning to move back
into balance and homeostasis so
gratitude you know the funny thing about
gratitude is that we're conditioned and
hypnotized into believing that we need a
reason to be be grateful know when you
get when you when something happens to
you or something's happening to you when
you're receiving something or you've
received something you feel gratitude
you say thank you well when you start to
feel gratitude ahead of the actual
experience the emotional signature of
gratitude means it's happening to you
it's already happened to you that
gratitude is the ultimate state of
receiving so you can take a person who
has been diagnosed with cancer say as an
example and they're living in fear and
turning that Battleship around instead
of them surrendering to fear every day
you teach them how to surrender to love
or to gratitude and when they start
self-regulating well their immune system
is going to get stronger we know that uh
and at the same time the thought of them
getting better is going to make it into
the body because the thought is it can
be received by the feeling of gratitude
because the body's believing believing
as the unconscious mind that it's in a
state to receive that something
wonderful is happening to it so you can
begin to program the autonomic nervous
system to work in a very different way
and um and and it takes it takes
practice but um but yes it's entirely
possible and and we and we see we we
measure this and once you know the skill
on how to do this it's it's just like
anything else like once you know how to
do it uh you can do it with your eyes
open as well as your eyes closed and you
can turn some of those very strong
chemicals that become we become like
addicts you know the it's a drug you
know the arousal of the stress hormones
uh people start to become very dependent
on them and and they use the problems
and conditions in their life to reaffirm
uh this emotional need to feel these uh
feel these chemicals and that means they
become addicted to the life they don't
even like you know and and and if you
can turn on that stress response just by
thought alone you can become addicted to
your own thoughts now this is this is a
challenge for people because this
explains why change is so hard but by
the same means just like an addict
overcoming heroin you're going to have
some Cravings you know you're going to
say hey it's been 2 days since you
suffered I mean come on the hardest part
about change is is not making the same
choices you did the day before and the
moment you decide to make a different
Choice get ready it's going to be
uncomfortable it's going to be
unfamiliar there it's going to be
unpredictable there's going to be some
uncertainty you're you're leaving the
known biologically neurologically
chemically hormonally genetically you're
stepping into a River to cross a river
to become somebody else and and when
people really start understanding that
their
personality creates their personal
reality and your personality is made up
of how you think how you act and how you
feel that means then the present
personality who's listening to this show
has created the present personal reality
called life and if you want to create a
new life new personal reality you got to
change your personality that means you
got to start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and changing become
aware of your unconscious habits and
behaviors and notice them and and look
at the emotions that you live by every
single day that keep you connected to
the past and decide the research shows
that when you come to a concept or an
idea you know and you're reading a book
or you're watching a documentary or
you're studying something and you come
to a concept or an idea where there's a
word that you don't understand or a
concept that's complicated and you're
not going back and understanding it do
you know that if you keep reading past
that point that your comprehension goes
down
incrementally so that you've just read
five pages you have no idea what you
read your awareness is in the freezer
with the
hogendas your brain is processing the
information but your awareness is
somewhere else that's because you got to
something that you didn't understand and
you continued on so if you can stay
present with this information and you
can work with your partner in building
the most complete model possible and you
can begin to integrate this into the
networks of neurons that you already
have every time we build this concept
and build it a little bit more you're
going to begin to wire that information
into your brain so that when we get to
this afternoon and it comes time to
apply all of this philosophical
theoretical intellectual information for
you to have an experience you have more
intention behind it and the research
shows that if you assign more meaning
behind what you're doing you get better
results this is a person who came into
our event with severe anxiety take a
look at the front of the
brain most of the brain in Delta and
Theta and Alpha and Beta And even high
beta the blue represents that there's no
energy in the frontal lobe now frontal
lobe is the CEO of the brain it's the
symphony leader if the boss of the
symphony leader is no longer leading the
orchestra leading the community the rest
of the brain has a very strong tendency
to move out of disorder just like any
organization 3 days of
meditation you can see that there's very
little red in the brain if there's no
blue and there's no red it represents
normal now you can see that there's
certain amount of symmetry that's taking
place on the right side there represents
that the person's in a more coherent and
balanced coherent brain wave state
another person comes to our event severe
anxiety you can see all that red in the
brain and high beta represents a lot of
uh vigilance and a lot of anxiety 3 days
later after the event you don't see any
red in there this person healed
themselves of anxiety as
well person with Parkinson's disease
Parkinson's disease is deficiency and
dopamine in the brain when there's not
enough dopamine in the brain the upper
motor neurons can't communicate with
each other when there's an aberant motor
function that's taking place in the
neurons of the brain it sends a very um
um signal to the body and people
experience involuntary Tremors with
Parkinson's disease 3 days of
meditation look at this this person's
brain represents way more coherence and
much less uh uh overactive brain
activity if you believe in yourself it
means you have to believe in possibility
and if you believe in possibility you're
going to have to believe in yourself and
so something really cool happens when
you do this that I just discovered
recently just watching people at our
weeklong events um you know cuz you got
to go all in you got to go all in and
it's 7 days and it's a lot and it's
super intense and there's times where
you don't want to show up because I'm
pushing people across the river of
change there comes a moment where people
keep showing up for themselves they keep
showing up for themselves in spite of
the weather in spite of their foot
hurting in spite of their bad dream in
spite of whatever their fight with or
whoever they keep showing up they get
really worthy to receive they it's no
they feel really worthy like I am worthy
to receive this gift and the universe
only gives us what we think we're worthy
of of receiving right so we got to get
to that point because so many people who
are in
lack somehow don't feel worthy right so
so the abundance
then becomes the sign that you finally
become worthy and for the soul it's not
about the abundance it's about mastering
your worthiness and the reflection is
the things that you accumulate listen my
dad used to say this to me all the time
he'd say wait wait wait wait a second
wait a second just sit down with me here
if anybody else can do it you could do
it also I would love for you to share
the mission that you're on and how
people can break past the memory of who
they've been so they can tap into the
potential of who they can be well a
habit is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition habit is when you've done
something so many times that your body
actually knows how to do it better than
your conscious mind
it's a habit so people wake up in the
morning and they run through the same
routine every single day and the routine
is maed out neurologically in their
brain if they have the thought of the
coffee maker they make the choice to go
over there they do the thing to make the
coffee they have the experience of
drinking it they feel the emotion
associated with it that becomes a
pattern it becomes more automatic it
becomes second nature so we have a
series of these redundant patterns then
and in time we lose our free
will to a set of programs and the body
is programmed into the predictable
future based on what we've done in the
past and that's how we lose the free
will to a set of
programs so that habituation is the
predictable future and that's the
known and other people wake up in the
morning and they romance their memories
of the past they they think about the
problems that they have have in their
lives and those problems are connected
to certain people and certain objects
and certain things at certain times and
places and since the brain is a record
of the past the moment they remember
that problem they're thinking in the
past and every one of those problems has
an emotion that's associated with
it so the moment the person feels
unhappy the moment the person feels fear
the moment the person feels unworthy the
moment the person feels sad now the
body's in the past because thoughts of
the language of the brain and feelings
of the language of the body and how we
think and how we feel creates our state
of
being and so it's that thought and that
feeling it's that image or that memory
in the emotion it's that stimulus and
response that's conditioning the body to
become mind of that emotion and now the
body is so
objective that it does not know the
difference between the real life
experience that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that person is creating
by thought alone and the body's reliving
the same past experience over and over
again and if we can't think greater than
how we feel or feelings have become the
means of thinking than we're thinking in
the past and if we believe that our
thoughts have anything to do with our
destiny then our future is going to look
a lot like our
past so that familiar past also is the
known and so what we discovered is that
if you could teach a
person to when their body is sitting in
a meditation as an
example and it's off schedule it's used
to feeling angry at 8:00 in the morning
because it watches the news uh the
person experiences traffic every day
they get 11:00 they check their
emails and they start judging other
people you know there's a there's a set
of familiar emotions that person has
been living by we discovered that if a
person can sit past that me memory that
they can sit past that emotion that
causes them to get aroused to get
frustrated to get impatient that's the
emotion that causes the person to quit
and they have this conclusion that they
can't meditate or they can't focus or
they have ADD it's a story they tell
themselves about the
past we discovered though that when a
person sits past those those thoughts
that say I can't it's too hard I'll
never change I need a brain scan there's
something wrong with me it's my mother
fault and they're curious to see what's
on the other side of that thought when
their body gets aroused and frustrated
instead of giving up and saying um I
have too many things to do that they
actually learn a way to settle the body
back down into the present moment and
it's David versus Goliath and every time
we can become conscious that we get
emotional we get frustrated get
impatient and we settle the body down we
executing the
will now that's greater than the program
and the body is no longer the mind the
person is now becoming conscious of
their unconscious self and it takes an
enormous amount of
energy it takes an enormous amount of
awareness to stay present because to
stay present is to be in the unknown
that's when you can't predict the future
and that's not when you're remembering
the past and the unknown in the program
that we have as biological creatures is
a scary place
is it's better to run from the unknown
than to hang out in it wake up every day
how bad you want it how bad do you want
in your dream it's so much easier to
forget that Vision than to remember it
right so if you're going to remember it
you got to keep it alive in your mind
how do you keep it alive in your mind
you you disconnect from your environment
you close your eyes you play music in
the background you sit your body down
and it's got to pee and it's got to eat
and it's got to you just just sit down
for a few minutes like training a dog
like yeah stay when I say it's time to
get up we get up don't be thinking about
what's going to happen in your day you
already know what going to happen don't
think what happened yesterday you
already know that get in the present
moment and say who do I want to be when
I open my eyes who do I want to be today
what would greatness look like huh how
how would I how would one day one shot
one lifetime what would an abundant
person do let me rehearse that with my
eyes closed let me remind myself who I
don't want to be let me remind myself
who do I want to be let's not get up
leis until we get that till we till
where the tennis ball hits The Sweet
Spot when you go oh I'm ready for the
day now now game on now if you can
maintain that modified State of Mind and
Body the entire day without defaulting
by seeing someone or doing something
stay in that state the experiment still
continues and you're changing your
energy doesn't happen in 2 days you're
not that good right that's it you're not
that good we keep
practicing people who show up the for
the 21 weeks in a row this woman 21
weeks in a row the end of 21 weeks she
knew it boom her whole life changed boom
was the 21 days worth it ask her the
experiment she was just changing the
process and living in stress is when
your response to the
environment causes you to activate the
autonomic nervous system and when you
activate that autonomic nervous system a
branch of it called the sympathetic
nervous system the figh ORF flight
nervous system is mobilizing all of the
body's
energy all the body's resources for some
danger in the outer environment are you
with me still and it mobilizes all this
energy to prepare the body to do one of
three things to fight to run or to
freeze and hide and so the mobilization
and tapping all of the body's resources
causes the heart to race respiratory
rate to increase pupils to dilate
digestive juices to shut down blood sent
to the extremities the immune system
dials up then dials down we mobilize all
this glucose to have the energy to be
able to run fight or hide now in the
short term that works really well all
organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term
stress the human beings were a little
bit more
complex sometimes it's not the Predator
that we're afraid of it's the person
sitting next to us at work sometimes
it's the news sometimes it's a reaction
to someone or something
and the constant knocking the brain and
body out of balance causes that
imbalance to become a new balance and
now the person is headed for some type
of breakdown some type of disease
because no organism can live in that
state emergency state for an extended
period of time this is The Telltale
moment if human beings have what it
takes to truly be able to solve the
problem problems that we've created from
a limited level of Consciousness from a
greater level of Consciousness the
answers are all around us we just got to
wake up whatever it is from global
warming to politics monetary uh systems
it's all there just we just have to
emerge as a
collective that's
connected by the energy of Love of
gratitude of freedom and to not shrink
in fear or hostility or suffering as
these changes take place because now
we're at the same vibrational energy
that's created them and so we have to
change our attitude and invite these
changes and believe that something
Greater is Coming you see we are the
people that we're waiting
for that's it we're the people we're
waiting for so why not just wake up so
if I can
[Music]
contribute to that evolution in some way
if me personally it's not about Jo
dispens I have no interest in that I've
given that up a long time ago what I do
have a fundamental interest
in
is what's possible for human beings and
it should never be about me it should be
about them because they I want them to
experience their own empowerment and you
can't tell me you're too old you can't
tell me you're too sick you can't tell
me you're too overweight or underweight
or uh had too tough of a past or your
life is too Fallen you can't tell me any
of those things any longer can't even
tell me you don't even meditate never
meditated before I've seen all of every
one of those excuses in every
different genre experience
transformation which means then nobody
is so special to be excluded from this
phenomenon
and so I hope that I leave a mark uh in
some way that Empower people to no
longer believe that they're limited it's
so easy to believe we're limited once
they realize that they're empowered and
they're unlimited get out of the way and
if they're tempering those
emotions and they're overcoming those
addictions to those emotions they'll see
the hidden meaning behind all things and
they'll they they won't necessarily
believe everything they're seeing on the
news they'll see the way it really is
because they're no longer controlled by
those emotions they're at a greater
level of energy and emotions are energy
and nobody changes until they change
their energy and when you change your
energy you change something in your life
it's the law so people are people are
doing it we're at the point where
they're doing it and some of them are
becoming it and when you become it no
one can take it away from you it's yours
if you could learn how to rest your
attention in your heart and where you
place your attention as is where you
place your
energy regulate your breath start
slowing your breathing down even if you
did it for one minute you could actually
begin to change your brain waves MH and
you could actually cause your heart to
start functioning more regulation and
more or order if you said okay I'm going
to work with my body and I'm going to
start breathing and I'm going to start
feeling emotions that I do want to feel
yes it may take you a few minutes to get
there but if you keep practicing it over
and over again the heart starts
producing a very profound signal it
starts to produce an external magnetic
field it's it's it's
measurable so now you have a coherent
brain which means you can get very
intentional and you have a coherent
heart which means you can feel the
emotions of your future before it
happens somehow you have this
broadcasting of this wi-fi signal uh and
the Brain tends to be electrical in
nature so it's sends out an electrical
charge into the field the heart is the
magnetic charge it's what draws things
to us it's the it's the magnetic field
and now you actually by changing the way
you think and the way you feel you're
changing the signal in the field and if
you're able to maintain that state for
an extended period of time I say
something magical is going to happen in
your life something unusual some unknown
experience is going to occur if you keep
thinking the same way and feeling the
same way your life should stay the
same while we do the energy thing from
the center I've had this experiences
wherein I'm sitting up and I just fall
down it's so intense that it keeps
shaking me and I get scared so what is
your opinion
about come here it happens to me all the
time you know we have physical bodies
those are vehicles for us to inhabit yes
or no yes and we have traumas we have
injuries we have emotional blockages and
all of that is
organized as condensed energy in the
body in other words your body is
gravitationally organized energy light
and information packaged in cellular
form are you with me still yes and you
got all this energy all this vital life
force sitting down there and when you
begin to disrupt it and you learn how to
move it it's like a champagne bottle
when it goes off it's a moving freight
train and when that energy begins to
erupt and the sympathetic nervous system
releases it it's going to move through
different parts of your body and it's
going to begin to break through certain
certain
restrictions and when you start getting
afraid of it and you start Contracting
the contraction does what causes more
impedance and so then the body is trying
to process information because all that
energy is carrying information and when
it strikes your brain flash a light and
there you are on the ground
and you know and everybody's freaking
out of and you're thinking wow this is
pretty cool it feels pretty
amazing but it's an known and a lot of
people get afraid of it and I went
through many many years that sometimes I
would just hear a song and i' would be
like oh no it's going to happen and it
just wasn't appropriate at certain times
but you're doing it right you're doing
exactly what I want you to do you you
got a you got a A good release of energy
going to your brain and your nervous
system has to be able to process a very
powerful frequency and when that energy
begins to move and it moves up into your
brain and you start creating that field
your body's got to process that energy
with the information and as it does a
lot of times it just is trying to take
it in and your body's going through that
whole
process the key is to surrender
completely to it just relax into it and
let it happen to you and it'll turn into
something else it just will it did for
me well love you to speak into how when
we find coherence when we find alignment
between brain and heart then we can we
can Steward whatever reality we want to
us in in record time yeah so one of the
things that we we do is we when you're
agitated at someone and on a zoom call
and you know you're doing
the and you're thinking about five ways
to throttle them you know I'm joking but
you get the idea you're aroused by
something that knocks you out of balance
and you're sitting there you know your
heart's beating against the closed
system it's pumping blood but you're not
running you're not fighting you're not
hiding and it starts it starts creating
problems the heart starts beating out of
order out of
rhythm and so we discovered when we
started seeing teaching
people how to place their attention on
their heart when they where you place
your attention is where you place your
and out of all the things that you feel
with you know what I'm talking about
with your body we ask people to feel
with nothing but their heart and where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy and
we we started seeing we started hooking
up the heart the the ECG monitors with
the brain and every time the heart would
flux into coherence you would see this
wave of alpha just this beautiful
coherent wave of alpha heart was telling
the brain create and Alpha is a creative
state and when we're in Alpha we see in
pictures we see in images we're
imagining when we're in beta we're
thinking we're analyzing it's the voice
in your head so we saw that when the
person dropped into their heart really
well there was this kind of wave of
information that that went to the brain
and caused the brain to become very
coherent and it was always after the
heart uh doing was in that state and so
we started realizing that the heart was
the creative Center it was it's it's
when we move out of these first three
centers and we move into our heart when
we move into that Center The Heart
starts telling the brain starts
informing the brain so we started
building instruments with in with our
brain scientists and our and our
scientific team where we could actually
see how this kind of phenomena worked
and so when a person starts putting
their attention in their heart we start
seeing this uh low frequency this very
low frequency in the heart that's only
indigenous to the heart start to fill up
like a gas tank just the person's just
putting their attention on their heart
and they're giving their heart the
energy it needs to beat that's what that
frequency is about so we feeding it an
energy so we see it kind of go up like a
gas tank and then we see the
parasympathetic nervous SYM come up with
it and what does that mean the person's
relaxing right so now they're relaxing
but then all of a sudden we see the
parasympathetic nervous system about to
drop down and here comes the sympathetic
nervous system and now the person's
having a little
arousal and we started discovering that
when this occurs when a person is
relaxed in their heart there's energy
that moves to the brain the person
starts seeing possibilities that they
they never saw before and so getting
really good at relaxing in your heart
and Awakening your brain causes this
kind of synchronization that takes place
between the two they're they're dancing
together in this really beautiful way
and when they're uh in the same or
similar frequency uh if you're sharing
the same frequency you're sharing the
same information now the brain may think
but the heart knows and I'm I'm telling
you it is a straight shooter it does not
beat around the bush at all and now the
heart starts telling informing the brain
giving it the information that the
person needs for themselves in their
lives we can do this we take people we
can train them to do this and they can
do it in 15 minutes and when when they
start getting really good at relaxing
more in their heart and more energy
begins to move into their brain we start
seeing this very crazy thing happened in
the brain where delta waves are now
carrying theta waves and theta waves are
carrying alpha waves and alpha waves are
carrying beta waves and beta waves are
carrying High beta waves and high beta
waves carrying gamma waves and the whole
entire brain is functioning in resonance
they patterns within patterns within
patterns within patterns that person is
having a very profound uh transcendental
moment so we work with getting really
relaxed in our hearts and awake in our
brain we do it so much
I want people to get so good at doing it
with their eyes
closed they can do it with their eyes
open because relax in the heart and wake
in the brain is so much better than
stressed out unconscious and living in a
program what can we do on a moment by
moment basis when we catch ourselves and
realize we're riding our emotions look I
mean there's nothing wrong with an
emotional reaction I still have them I
mean we all do the question is how long
are you going to have it that's the real
question and if you can't break that
emotional reaction then it means on some
level you must be addicted to that
emotion because an addiction is
something you think you can't stop so
imagine then when you start reacting
most people don't think that they have
the ability to stop it so they don't
they think the person out there is doing
it to me or that situation is creating
it so once we say that we're victims
because we have no control over
ourselves so when we start reacting the
first thing to do is to stop take a
breath Center yourself bring up an
elevated emotion and I know that a lot
of times you don't want to do it because
you want to feel angry and you want to
feel frustrated and you want to feel
fear because that's the normal reaction
so so the first step in any process of
change is becoming aware so you may just
say my gosh now I'm aware that I'm Ang R
now that I'm aware that I'm fearful
that's the first step the second step is
doing something about it taking a moment
excusing yourself from the conditions in
your life just for a few minutes
centering your I just did it yesterday
centering myself taking a couple breaths
raising my energy and working with my
body so it's I don't I don't do that for
four hours because turns out uh we lose
a lot of energy and we also start
downregulating genes that start creating
disease so so the second step is really
uh executing A Change by creating an
elevated State and so you begin to lower
the volume to those survival emotions
and of course you begin to cultivate
elevated emotions and it makes sense
that our students who practice this
every single day and doing the inner
work it's becoming a skill for them and
we see some students that are able to
sustain those States for over an hour at
a time which means they don't have all
their attention on their Out World now
they're actually paying more attention
to their inner world and they're not
putting all their attention out there
and that what allows them to catch it
when they start feeling a certain way so
so you got to practice just like you
just can't go out and hit a tennis ball
unless you start practicing and the more
you practice and the more you do the
work the same thing happens with your
ability to be able to regulate and
change different states when you give
people sound scientific information and
science is the Contemporary language of
mysticism it's science that demystifies
the
mystical and once they can understand it
and they can learn it they're forging
new Connections in their brain that's
what learning is if they have a model of
understanding that they can
theoretically begin
to process in their mind and it makes
sense to them the research shows that if
you don't review that information that
you've learned if you don't repeat it if
you don't think about it over and over
again the circuits that you've just
forged will weak and they'll prune apart
and you won't remember so if learning is
making new synaptic connections then
remembering is maintaining them so if a
person can explain that to somebody and
they
can build that model with someone else
and they can explain that model they're
beginning to install the neurological
Hardware in their brain and preparation
for the experience and as I said the
more they understand what they're doing
the more they understand why they're
doing it the how tends to get easier and
they can assign meaning to the process
so we
started putting people through this
process and then I thought well if we
can set up the conditions in the
environment and give them the proper
instructions a certain percentage of the
people will get their behaviors to match
their intentions they'll get their
actions equal to their thoughts when
they get their mind and body working
together they'll have a new experience
and that experience then enriches the
philosophical circuits in their brain
and the moment those neurons begin to
organize into networks the brain makes a
chemical and that chemical is called a
feeling or an emotion so the payoff from
every experience is that chemical
signature called an emotion and so the
moment they started to feel empowered
the moment they started to feel more
unlimited the more they started to feel
free the more they started to feel
grateful from some experience they were
teaching their body chemically to
understand what their mind is
intellectually understood I started to
realize that knowledge is for the mind
and experience is for the body and I
started to see that people started to
embody the truth of that Philosophy from
the experience and that was the
information that began to select and
instruct new genes and they started to
change on a very basic level I like to
just get myself in my think box
organizing what am I not going to think
about what am I going to stay away from
what am I not going to do in my
meditation me review that what am what
am I going to do when I get that all
worked out then I get in my playbox in
my playbox there's no thinking I've got
all the thinking done in my think box my
play box it's really about me changing
my state and so um I allow for two hours
every morning doesn't mean I always take
it or need it let me say that but I
allow for two hours sometimes I like to
just get my mind straight and then uh I
do the work I do the work and and uh I
like to get to that point where when I'm
done I feel like something changed do
the work yeah what does the work look
like it's meditation yeah it's finding
the present moment it's getting into the
unknown it's getting Beyond Myself
disconnecting from my body getting
Beyond any thought of anyone or anything
getting Beyond Time moving beyond space
and
time turns out when you focus on nothing
there are so many amazing things that
happen to your brain I've seen this
scans over and over
again what have you seen in the
scans well there's this thing in the
brain called
modularity and when we're living uh by
the hormones of stress and stress is
when you can't predict something
when you can't control something or you
have the perception that something's
going to get worse you switch on that
fight ORF flight nervous system and the
rush of those chemicals causes us to
become alert to become aroused and we
narrow our focus on the material world
and so when you're not able to control
everything in your life and you can't
predict everything in your life you
start shifting your attention to
everyone and everything every person
every object every place we've all had
that experience when we're under stress
and every one of those people those
objects those things those places has a
neurological Network in the brain so
like a lightning storm in the clouds the
brain begins to fire out of order very
incoherently it becomes modulated or
compartmentalized It's A house divided
against itself and those individual
compartments don't talk to the rest of
the brain and we tend to get overfocused
you never notice when you're under
stress you're obsessing about something
you're over focusing about something
you're overthinking something you're
overanalyzing you're driving your brain
higher and higher into higher states of
arousal High beta brain wave
patterns we discovered that if you teach
a person to go from a narrow focus on
something physical something material
and broaden their focus open their
awareness and put their attention on
space on nothing and create what's
called a Divergent Focus the act of
sensing and no longer analyzing thinking
begins to slow the brain waves down from
that beta brain wave state to a lowlevel
beta and then all of a sudden to Alpha
if if they keep doing it sensing space
tends to cause those different
compartments that were modulated or
divided to begin to synchronize and what
syns in the brain actually links in the
brain so the brain starts firing in a
more holistic state in other words every
single area of the brain is resonating
at the same frequency and now the brain
is functioning as one neurological
network instead of individuals that kind
of holism that kind of order feels
really good feels really good and so
people practice slowing their brain
waves down not only to get beyond the
analytical mind but to cause the brain
to fire in a more coherent way and if
we're going to have a clear intention
about what we want the more coherent the
brain the clearer the intention so we've
seen in seven days even in four days
these dramatic changes in the levels of
coherence and order that take place in
the brain the brain's firing in a more
holistic State that's when the person
notices a change in their anxiety and
the depression and their PS PTSD
whatever it is there's more order in the
brain and and uh the act of focusing on
nothing and opening your awareness to
space creates that kind of amazing
change I wanted to uh take a few moments
and and connect with uh this community
on Facebook here um live streams and the
reason that I wanted to do that is
because number one we have a community
that's growing of close to 7
6,000 uh participants and people and um
now that I have the time to uh uh to
look and to see um what questions people
ask and uh investigate the numerous
different uh types of um Facebook
communities there are I wanted to spend
a little bit of time with all of you and
and let you know that I see you um I've
seen your questions um I know uh that
this is such a a broad uh Community we
have people that have attended one live
stream uh we have people that have been
to four or five weeklong events and it's
a it's a big variation in um people's
understanding and and people's uh
experience and and I wanted to to just
connect with all of you and let you know
that a community you know our our
community our Advanced Community as one
Community is a is a group of people that
share the same principles and share the
same ideas and and if you're part of
this community it means on some level
that uh you believe that um the way you
think and the way you feel has some
effect on your life and and communities
are built on the exchange of ideas and
the exchange of ideas is really how we
communicate the other thing is the
agreement on those ideas if we share the
same understanding of possibility if we
share the same understanding of quantum
phys physics and and the scientific
model of how mind affects the nature of
reality then we'd have to understand
mind and its intricacies and the
Neuroscience of neuroplasticity and and
and how your mind affects your body and
is there electromagnetism that is the
result of thoughts and feelings and and
and uh can we change our gene expression
and all of these different
idealisms uh tend to create a bond or
create uh a community uh but one of the
other things that's so important that I
find really
valuable is experience and when we share
the same experiences uh we share the
same emotions and when we share the same
emotions we share the same energy and a
community of people that is inseparable
uh during these times of separation and
isolation uh are people that understand
that they can connect uh in a
like-mindedness uh in in a frequency and
an awareness a Consciousness and if
we're unconscious then we don't see
possibilities uh but when we become
conscious through knowledge and
information I think it's so important
because when we learn something new we
see possibilities we didn't see before
and so many people uh in uh this this
community uh your community are asking
really good questions how do I heal my
body um how do I produce elevated
emotions um they ask for help and re
recommendations on what book to read
where should they start um what
meditations to get how do I become
abundant and the fact that you're asking
how is really
important uh because information
knowledge understanding philosophy
theory is the first step to understand
what you're doing and why you're doing
it but when you make the effort really
make the effort to get started started
and initiate what you've learned into
practicum into a practical
experience um now you're putting the
rubber to the road and those questions
should come up because the how means you
want to understand better what you're
doing and why you're doing it because
you made it this far in a video I want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you are
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Michael Singer motivation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there mindfulness is
about this it is about finally waking up
one day and saying I'm the boss I being
here I have a mind I can do better with
it than letting it scare me all the time
than letting it remind me of everything
ever bothered me